Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zum Chaos Radio 283, dieses Mal mit gemerkter Nummer und wie
immer mir, Markus Richter.
Ich versuche hier Ordnung reinzubringen in den chaotischen Haufen, der dieses Mal das
Halbjahreszeugnis für die Ampelkoalition ist und es oft dauert es ja total lange zu
erklären, warum sich die Sendung heute mit was so beschäftigt, aber heute ist es wirklich ganz einfach.
Wir haben eine Regierung, die Regierung hat vier Jahre Zeit, um Dinge zu tun, zwei sind vorbei.
Was bis jetzt gut geklappt hat und natürlich mit dem Fokus auf das Digitale. Und dazu sind heute
hier Konz und Erdgeist, beides SprecherInnen des Chaos Computer Clubs Deutschland. Hallo und herzlich
willkommen. Wunderschönen guten Tag. Guten Tag. Und außerdem Elisa vom Superlab. Hallo. Hi. Ein
Labor für die feministische digitale Zukunft. Was genau ist das? Genauer gesagt für feministische
digitale Zukunft, weil wenn, dann wollen wir schon mehrere davon haben.
Ja, das ist eine NGO, ein Zusammenschluss von Leuten, die die Welt anzünden wollen, beides.
Ja, also vorbehaltlos, ja, genau. Wir arbeiten daran, an dieser ominösen Schnittstelle von Digitalisierung und Gesellschaft, wie alle, aber wir eben mit einer Zukunftsperspektive und an Grundsatzgerechtigkeitsfragen der Gesellschaft.
Auch da werden wir heute noch ein Auge drauf werfen, ob sich das geändert hat, weil, wie
Konz am Anfang, ganz richtig gesagt hat, also am Anfang sozusagen, bevor diese Sendung angefangen
hat, also unsichtbar quasi gesagt hat, ist ja nicht nur vier Jahre Regierung, also die
jetzt neue Regierung, die vier Jahre Zeit hat, sondern auch zwei Jahre nach 16 Jahren
Merkel, nach 16 Jahren CDU und andere Parteien.
Da könnte man ja denken, jetzt wird alles...
Anders. Ich wollte gerade gut sagen, aber der deutsche politische Betrieb hat mich sozusagen zynisch genug zu machen, um vielleicht zu denken, es wird nur alles anders.
Ich habe das nur erwähnt, weil man das fast wieder vergessen hat, dass irgendwie diese Ära vorbei ist, weil dieser Scholz als Bundeskanzler irgendwie so merkelt.
Also man hat vergessen, mit welchen Hoffnungen viele in diese neue Ampelregierung gestartet sind. Deswegen habe ich das nur erwähnt, bevor wir hier angefangen haben aufzuzeichnen.
Ich finde, also vielleicht ist das, also wenn wir jetzt erst noch mal über die Gestalt am Bug reden, was ich ja total bemerkenswert finde, ist, dass, wenn ich an BundeskanzlerInnen denke, dann denke ich sozusagen, ja, wir hatten ja gerade die Merkel und davor war ja der Schröder, wie alt wir alle sind, und jetzt ist der Kanzler sozusagen so gesichtslos, also ich habe auch heute sozusagen in der Diskussion um die Digitalpolitik, habe ich nicht die Erwartung, dass wir über Olaf Scholz reden,
Sondern, dass es andere Menschen gibt, die Politik machen oder versauen. Aber er ist so mega unsichtbar.
Und er hat keine digitalen Themen im Wahlkampf gehabt. Er hat im Wesentlichen keine digitalen Themen.
Er geht in diesem Bereich irgendwie als Nullnummer. Also es ist nicht, dass er dazu mal irgendwas sagt.
Gibt es einen Bereich, wo er nicht... Entschuldigen Sie die Frage, aber...
Er hat mit Finanzen Ahnung, du Privatbanken. Aber Finanzen vergisst er ja auch.
Der hat eine Piratenklappe auf. Seitdem kennt ihn die Welt, muss man mal sagen. Seitdem ist er auch anderswo.
Aber auch nur deswegen. Und das ist natürlich schon ein schwieriges Zeugnis auszustellen.
Aber die Frage ist, wofür war Merkel jetzt bekannt im Ausland? Außer für Steady Hand?
Merkel hat die Krisen in den Jahrzehnten gelöst, dafür war sie bekannt.
Die war auch Beraterin für viele Staatsmänner, die auch schon Jahre auf ihrem Dessert sitzen.
Also und sie hat sich auch hier äußert, ich darf mich an so was erinnern, wie wir schaffen das.
Also, Eminem politische… Oder Neuland war da auch.
Ja, also ich will das jetzt nicht bewerten, aber… Was du da zusammenfasst, sind aber sehr, sehr große Metathemen, die irgendwie…
Ja, aber sie war halt da.
Wo sie reingewachsen ist. Ich weiß nicht, wie das zum Anfang aussah, als sie den Kohl abgesägt hat.
Möglicherweise, also Erdgeist, der große Relativierer. Wir entfernen uns aber auch.
Was ist denn hier los? Genau, steigen wir ein, steigen wir um, steigen wir ein in die Digitalpolitik und die, das wird vielleicht gar nicht sozusagen das wichtigste Thema der Regierung sein, aber ich nehme jetzt mal an, sozusagen in meiner Klischee, ich setze mir die Leinenbrille auf-Frage, ist eines der Themen, die in Deutschland, wenn man digital denkt, dann geht ja sofort das große Seufzen los und das fängt ja da an, dass nicht alle Leute einen Internetanschluss haben oder vielleicht technisch korrekter formuliert, kein Internetanschluss, der den Namen auch wirklich verdient.
Breitbandausbau. Ich erinnere mich sozusagen auch in der Merkel-Ära hatten wir viele Chaosradios, wo wir immer zusammengekommen sind am Ende der Legislaturperiode und gesäuft haben und gesagt haben, naja, immerhin, jetzt gibt es schon zwei Internetanschlüsse mehr.
Wir gehen heute verschiedene Bereiche durch und ich stelle jedes Mal die Frage, was haben Sie versprochen und wie sieht es denn jetzt wirklich aus?
So, Breitbandausbau, was haben sie uns versprochen, wieviel Mbit haben wir alle seit letztem Jahr
und ja, erstmal das, was haben sie versprochen, es gibt ja einen Koalitionsvertrag, stand
das da überhaupt drin?
Da stand eine Zwischenüberschrift drin im Koalitionsvertrag, der hieß Tempo beim Infrastrukturausbau.
Ausrufezeichen, unser Ziel ist die flächendeckende Versorgung mit Glasfaser und dem neuesten
Mobilfunkstandard, das stand da drin.
Ich habe wenig Material von 2023 gefunden. Ende 2022 gab es das große Rumheulen, weil
viele große Firmen schon in 2020, 2021 überhaupt den Glasfaserausbau wieder gestoppt haben.
Vodafone hat das komplett zurückgezogen und musste dann 180 Grad Drehung machen, um dann
wieder den Anschluss nicht zu verlieren. Wir haben Ende 2022 das Problem gehabt, dass es
dass es immer noch zu wenig Tiefbau-Kapazitäten in Deutschland überhaupt gibt.
Sie haben sich Bautrupps bis von Spanien herangeholt, um überhaupt buddeln zu können.
Das heißt, dort fehlt schlicht Personal und dass immer noch zu viel Bürokratie ist,
dass für den Tiefbau die Genehmigungsverfahren der Bauämter… Also ich habe das Gefühl, du beantwortest die Frage irgendwie.
Ja. Aber ich wollte ja erstmal wissen, was im Koalitionsvertrag steht.
Da steht drin, dass es Bautrupps aus Spanien… Das Zitat eben war alles, was da drin stand.
Ach das war alles, was da drin stand? Ja.
Okay. Ja gut. Also Koalitionsverträge zeichnen sich in der Regel nicht durch Details aus.
Was da ja drin steht ist, wir wollen das machen, nur nicht, bis wann, wie und so, aber sie
wollen es machen. War ihnen wichtig. Es gab sozusagen vielleicht von...
Nein, also ich habe zumindest nichts gefunden. Also ich kann jetzt wieder nur von einer anekdotischen Evidenz reden.
Also ich hier mitten in Berlin wohnt, habe gerade einen Brief von der Telekom bekommen.
Wir bauen Glasfaser aus, was für mich eine gute Nachricht ist, weil ich am Ende sozusagen
eines DSL-Verteilerstrangs hänge und nur eine sehr geringe Bandbreite herbekomme.
Das heißt aus meiner persönlichen Perspektive total super, aber wie sieht es denn aus?
Dass jetzt gerade die Telekom bei dir vorbeikommt, die hat ja viel Kritik dafür bekommen, dass
sie Überausbau betrieben hat in Regionen, die schon gerade von Glasfaser versorgt wurden.
Auch nochmal Glasfaser hinterherzuwerfen, um dann den kleinen neuen aufstrebenden kommunalen
Versorgern das Leben schwerer zu machen. Das heißt, die ganzen Ausbauzahlen, die ich jetzt über die letzten Jahre gelesen
habe, sind auch immer mit so einem Körnchen Salz zu genießen.
Man weiß nicht genau, wie viele Haushalte das wirklich sind.
Und die wirklich traurige Nummer, die dazu kommt, ist das bisschen...
Warte mal, nur, dass ich es richtig verstehe. Es gibt Ausbauzeilen, die Ausbauzeilen sagen, es gibt so und so viele neue Glasfaseranschlüsse.
Es ist aber möglich, dass sozusagen ein Haushalt einen neuen Glasfaseranschluss bekommen hat,
der schon einen Glasfaseranschluss hat.
Und das wird dann zweimal gezählt.
Und dann, um das ein bisschen weiter zu detaillieren, es gab wegen des mangelnden Breitbandausbaus,
stellenweise oder ortsweise Initiativen, wo also Leute sich zusammengeschlossen haben
Wir gründen jetzt keinen Verein oder eine kleine Firma, wir machen das hier lokal und
wir bauen dann schönen Glasfaser hin und in dem Moment, wo das passiert ist, ist die
Telekom gekommen und hat gesagt, ja geil, hier liegen ja schon die Leitungen, da können
wir noch unsere eigene Glasfaser durchschießen.
Das war noch gemeiner, sie haben gesagt, wo ihr schon mal buddelt.
Wir haben übrigens Gesetze, die eigentlich gegen uns gemacht wurden, das werden wir schon
mal anfangen mit buddeln, dass dann auch die kommunalen Betreiber von Strom und Gas und
Wir wissen schon, diese neuen, gerade ausgebuddelten Schächte mitbenutzen dürfen.
Telekom hat gesagt, so praktisch, ihr habt gerade gebuddelt, habt gerade genug Geld zusammen
gesammelt in der Kommune, wir werfen mal unsere Glasfaser auch mit rein.
Da sind wir an der Stelle, wo wir sagen können, hier könnte doch die Politik tätig werden.
Ist sie das? Ne.
Hat dann wieder mit den Fäusten geschüttelt und sich beschwert, aber sie hat dann nichts getan.
Meine Lieblingszahl, die ich jetzt in dieser Recherche gefunden habe, ist aber, was meinst
sondern wie viele von den rumliegenden Glasfaseranschlüssen in den Häusern tatsächlich aktiviert wurden von potenziellen Benutzerinnen.
Ich kenne so eine kleine Siedlung in Brandenburg, wo exakt das passiert ist, wo die eine Faser hingelegt haben.
Und ich kenne ja Leute, die sind mit Begeisterung auf diesen Anschluss draufgesprungen, aber
ich glaube es war nur ein Drittel. 26 Prozent. Wow.
Naja gut, die Frage ist, wir haben jetzt einen kleinen Blick drauf geworfen, die Frage, inwieweit
man nicht nur der Ampel ankreiden darf, ist natürlich auch… Kannst du das auseinandernehmen? Was hätte die Ampel tun können, was sie nicht getan hat?
Sie hat ja nicht konkretisiert, was sie tun will, aber sicherlich hätte sie da ein bisschen anders regulieren können oder auch Druck ausüben können, klar.
Inwiefern?
Naja, die Telekom hat sich ja eigentlich nur gesetzmäßig verhalten, in dem, was ihr zuerst ganz beschrieben habt, klar.
Dass die Bauämter da nicht mehr die Hufe in die Hand nehmen. Da kann man auch mit sanftem Druck in die Kommunen rein oder vielleicht mit Anreizen dafür sorgen, dass das sich verbessert.
Und dann kann man natürlich mit digitalen Angeboten, die dafür sorgen, dass die Teilnehmerinnen
da draußen auf dem Dorf ihren Glasfaseranschluss gar nicht wissen, wozu sie den außer zum
Fußball gucken benutzen sollen. Immerhin.
Ja, aber dafür haben sie ja Kabelfernsehen. Da brauchen sie ja, da reicht ihnen ja ihr Kupfer.
Okay, das ist die Glasfaser. Was ist denn mit 5G an jeder Milchkanne?
Das hängt ja eins zu eins damit zusammen, dass Glasfaser überall landet.
Das ist ja, du kannst ja keine 5G-Masten betreiben, die per Mikrowelle angeschlossen sind.
Musst du auch Glasfaser hinlegen. Wenn das Glasfaser noch nicht liegt, dann hast du das
gleiche Problem wie bisher, dass du 5G in dem vollen modernen Ausbau gar nicht betreiben
kannst, wenn du nicht schon Glasfaser überall hin gebuddelt hast.
Das klingt jetzt aber ein bisschen so, als wäre gar nichts passiert.
Muss man nochmal fragen. Also gibt es Breitbandausbau und der ist aber nicht so schnell, wie wir das gerne hätten?
Oder...
Bin ich der Einzige, der jetzt einen neuen Glasfaseranschluss bekommen hat?
Das sieht so aus, als ob sich's nicht beschleunigt hätte. Also das, was wir jetzt gerade sehen, dass das eh passiert wäre.
Von mir, Laie, Bauchgefühl, ich bin ja auch kein Kiefer-Experte.
Deswegen, das, was ich an Zahlen sehe, sieht so aus, als ob das eh so gewachsen wäre
und dass da die Koalition dort nichts verhindert, aber auch nichts beschleunigt hätte.
Kannst du nochmal die Schlagzeile vom Koalitionsvertrag vorlesen, die zwischengeschreibt?
Tempo. Tempo im Breitbandausbau.
Okay, also das klingt ja so ein bisschen wie drücken aufs Gaspedal, da kann man festhalten,
da haben sie nicht gemacht. Sie haben das quasi rollen lassen.
Ja. Das ist eine gute Beschreibung, würde ich auch sagen.
Ja gut, schön. Elisa, du hast noch gar nichts gesagt. Du meldest dich dann, wenn die Themen kommen, wo du, okay, nicht, dass hier jemand sozusagen
außen vor bleibt.
Da ist natürlich auch so ein bisschen Ermüdung bei dem ganzen Thema Breitbandausbau, den
wir glaube ich alle stark fühlen. Insofern können wir glaube ich nur konstatieren, es ist nicht genug passiert.
Ich erinnere mich noch, dass so ein bisschen im Vorfeld auch der Wahl immer wieder eingebracht wurde, das schwedische oder nordische Modell zu fahren, wo ganz stark über kommunale und auch genossenschaftlich betriebene Provider irgendwie zu machen.
Das Gegenmodell war dann so ein bisschen dieses Voucher-Modell, das irgendwie eingeführt wurde. Das steht auch noch als Schlagwort. Was ist das?
Soweit ich weiß, sollten da also irgendwelche Förderungen über Voucher ausgezahlt werden, um quasi so punktuell Gemeinden zu befähigen, Infrastrukturausbau selber in die Hand zu nehmen, aber ich, tatsächlich kenne ich die Zahlen nicht, ich weiß nur, es gibt, es tatsächlich umgesetzt wurde, das Gigabit-Grundbuch, das existiert ja jetzt und da kann man sich irgendwie informieren, welche Förderungsmöglichkeiten es gibt und welche Ausbaustufen auch in unterschiedlichen Regionen vorhanden sind, aber das ist halt eine Webseite.
Also ist jetzt auch nicht die ganz hohe Schwelle, mitzunehmen.
Ja, schade. Welche Note gebt ihr dann?
Naja, man könnte viel ausreichen, weil man nicht dagegen agiert hat. Also man hat jetzt auch nicht das Tempo gestoppt. Tempo ist ja versprochen worden, nicht viel mehr. Und Zahlen, an denen wir sie messen könnten, haben wir auch nicht.
Das ist so ein bisschen so ein Sportthema geworden. Alle, die nach Deutschland kommen, sagen immer, ja, hier, wo es kein Netz gibt, weiß nicht.
Es ist tatsächlich schwierig, weil, wie ich meinte, das Buddeln heißt, wie großes, schweres Material in viel Personal und wohin bekommen, da sieht man wahrscheinlich die Auswirkungen erst viel später.
Und selbst wenn da jetzt Dinge im Hintergrund passieren, die wir nicht mitbekommen, hat sich vielleicht die Regierung nicht brauchbar genug angestellt, das anzupreisen, was sie da tut.
Das heißt, es kann sein, dass jetzt plötzlich in zwei Jahren wir alle auf blühenden Landschaften…
Aber wir geben ja heute das Halbjahreszeugnis.
Ja. Also wärst du trotz bei einer Vier? Ich wäre bei einer Drei eher so.
3,5. 3 minus. 3 minus für den Breitbandausbau.
Naja gut, das kann man ja schon machen.
Ja, da hat man bestanden, meinst du.
Nächstes Thema, Lieblingsthema Überwachung.
Da haben wir glaube ich ein bisschen mehr zu sagen. Ja, also das erste, was ich fragen wollen würde, ist,
es ist ja eigentlich egal, wer im Innenministerium sitzt, Auch von der politischen Ausrichtung her.
Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist ja grundsätzlich eine gute Idee.
Hat man das Gefühl. Wer vorher irgendwie eine Position hatte, sitzt dann so.
Was steht im Koalitionsvertrag zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung? Und wann wurde versucht, sie wieder in Kraft zu setzen?
Es ist völlig eindeutig im Koalitionsvertrag. Die 3 Parteien haben sich darauf geeinigt,
dass es keine anlasslose Speicherung geben soll von Telekommunikationsverbindungsdaten.
Das ist ja die Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Sie haben auch noch ein Urteil kassieren müssen, ein höchstrichterliches vom ÖGH im Jahr 2022.
Weil ja die Telekom unter anderem, also das große deutsche Unternehmen, erfolgreich war.
Und die Gesetzgebung, die existiert hat, ist rechtswidrig. Was, kannst du noch kurz umreißen?
Es gab ja sozusagen von der Vorgängerregierung ein Gesetz. Also Telekommunikationsdaten speichern heißt sozusagen, wer telefoniert wann mit wem.
Und dazu gehören in der Regel auch noch gewisse Lokationsdaten, also Bewegungsdaten.
Und das ist ein langer Kampf. Also der erste Urteil zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist vom Jahr 2009.
Also das ist ein langer Kampf und das ist mittlerweile, glaube ich, das fünfte EuGH-Urteil.
Wir haben keine offensiven Forderungen der Regierung, allerdings der Opposition. Klar, die ist ja jetzt sozusagen die Union im Wesentlichen.
Und wir haben aber trotzdem einen gewissen Streit drum, denn nach dem Urteil 2022 ging natürlich die Kaffeesatzlesung los.
Was genau steht drin? Das Urteil ist aus meiner Sicht ziemlich eindeutig.
Es sagt nämlich, auch bei schweren Straftaten kann man nicht anlasslos speichern, also sozusagen ohne Unterschied.
Aber unsere Innenministerin hat dann überraschend beiseite gesagt, okay, aber bei IP-Adressen könnten wir doch vielleicht eine Ausnahme machen.
Also es gibt so eine Art Grundkonsens, würde ich sagen, dass es keine allgemeine Vorwärtsfahrtenspeicherung mehr geben soll, so wie es auch im Koalitionsvertrag steht.
Aber wenn es an die Details geht, dann vertritt Feser, die SPD-Mitglied, eine andere Position.
Aber aus meiner Sicht zumindest nicht sehr, also es ist nicht viel Druck hinter.
Was ich mich ja immer frage ist, das ist ja wirklich so, wenn Leute ins Innenministerium
kommen, ändern sie ja manchmal die Richtung.
Ich würde jetzt gerne hier so ein bisschen Kaffeesatzleserei betreiben wollen, glaubst
du oder glaubt ihr, dass es daran liegt, dass das Ministerium, da arbeiten ja dann Staatssekretäre
und eine Apparatur, die sozusagen auch unabhängig von Legislaturperioden Bestand hat, dass man
Wenn man sowas dann sagen muss, um das eigene Haus irgendwie sozusagen in Ruhe zu halten oder?
Also mein Eindruck ist, ihr Vorgänger war ja Horst Seehofer von der CSU.
Mein Eindruck ist, dass das Haus, das ist ja nun ein großes Ministerium, im wesentlichen personell bestehen blieb.
Nicht in jedem einzelnen Fall, aber schon.
Und dass aber so ein bisschen diese Hardcore-Positionen vertreten, die gegen den Koalitionsvertrag sind,
Und erst kam mit dem begehenden Wahlkampf, denn Nancy Faeser ist ja Kandidatin im hessischen Wahlkampf.
Und sie wird dann nicht Ministerpräsidentin werden, das wird wahrscheinlich eine ziemlich große Pleite für die SPD.
Aber man hat gemerkt, dass es eine Form von Wahlkampfprofilierung gab.
Ich glaube prinzipiell, dass man in diesem Haus nicht vermeiden kann, sehr stark mit den Anforderungen der Polizeien und Geheimdienste konfrontiert zu werden.
Und dass man andere gesellschaftliche Stimmen sehr viel weniger hört.
Also da ist dann halt ein Blickwinkel, der die Bedürfnisse der Ermittlungsbehörden sehr, sehr betont.
Also ich versuche das jetzt mal neutral zu formulieren. Aber könnte man das auch der Ampel-Kollektion ankreiden, dass das nach wie vor so ist?
Da gibt es aus Gründen wenig Widerstand. Das eine, weil dieses Hass im Netz-Thema und dieses irgendwie denkt dann keiner an die Kinder-Themen, die kommen immer wieder zurück auf, aber dem kann man nur begegnen, wenn man schon rechtzeitig alle Dinge gespeichert hat.
Und dann wird es immer wieder umformuliert, dann wird es immer wieder neu geframed, das wäre schon ganz praktisch, wenn wir da jetzt weiter anlasslos gespeichert hätten, dann könnte man ja den armen Kindern besser helfen.
Dann könnte man irgendwie auch der politischen Hassrede im Internet besser hinterhergehen.
Dort sieht man immer wieder auch aus der Koalition selber, denen das ein Anliegen ist,
die das ja auch in den Koalitionsvertrag mit reingeschrieben haben, die gesagt haben,
dass die Kinder da besser geschützt werden müssen, was ja bisher angeblich nicht passiert sei.
Und dass man sich den antidemokratischen Strömungen, die in diesen Hasskommentaren im Internet passieren,
dass man sich denen entgegenstellen muss und alles, was ihnen da einfällt, ist,
ja, dazu müssten wir die IP-Adressen gespeichert haben.
Und das geht dann nicht ganz zusammen mit ihren eigenen Ansagen, dass sie eigentlich nicht speichern wollen.
Aber das hörst du dann schon förmlich, wie dort zwei kollidierende Ideenrichtungen nicht zusammenpassen.
Wobei, um da mal direkt zu den Maßnahmen zu kommen, die jetzt schon vorgeschlagen wurden in den letzten zwei Jahren.
Es gibt natürlich den ersten Entwurf für ein Gesetz gegen digitale Gewalt, wie es sich nennt, ob der Name so gerechtfertigt ist.
Das wurde jetzt ja auch sehr intensiv debattiert, aber der kommt ja zumindest nicht aus dem
BMI, sondern aus dem BMJ.
Insofern sind ja auch immer noch mehrere Häuser daran beteiligt und ich habe das Gefühl,
das hat natürlich auch noch mal was gemacht mit der ganzen Entscheidungslage und mit der
inhaltlichen Ausweitung. Für die Vorratsseitenspeicherung ist das aber nicht der Gesetzentwurf, der ist unter
diesem Schlagwort Quick Freeze.
Da gibt es auch einen Gesetzentwurf.
Also dieses digitale Gewaltvorhaben ist nicht unmittelbar mit der Vorratsseitenspeicherung zusammenhängt.
Der Konflikt besteht ein bisschen zwischen den Häusern, wie auch eigentlich in früheren Regierungen.
Der Justizministerium vertritt sehr viel stärker eine grundrechteorientierte Politik, also das Bushman von der FDP.
Und der hat Quick Freeze vorgelegt und das ist eine Alternative zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Bedeutet, dass man ab einem gewissen Verdacht Daten einfriert und eben nicht anlasslos speichert.
Und da liegt ein Gesetzentwurf vor.
Und die digitale Gewalt, die sozusagen parallel läuft, ist aber nicht unbedingt ein Ersatz für die Vorratshaltensprechung. Kommt aber auch aus dem Justizministerium.
Aber dann lass uns doch mal bei dem Quick Freeze bleiben. Das ist sozusagen eine Verbesserung, Verdrächterung, neuer Wein in alten Schläuchen.
Ne, es wäre überhaupt eine Möglichkeit, dass… Ne, alter Wein in neuen Schläuchen.
Hier wirst du ein Same.
Es wäre überhaupt eine Möglichkeit, in irgendeiner Form Grundrecht konform zu machen.
Wir haben so viele Urteile, die klar machen, dass man anlasslos nicht darf.
Auch nicht bei schweren Straftaten. Man kann das ja lesen. Das steht in diesen Urteilen immer wieder drin.
Nee, aber das ist ja noch so... Du sagst oder ihr sagt sozusagen, dass das wäre eine Möglichkeit.
Wo man jetzt nicht, die man nicht sofort ganz anzünden muss.
So sagen die eigentlich schon immer, dass Quick Freeze wäre einer der Wege gewesen, so was zu tun, weil am Ende wollen wir als Club und wahrscheinlich auch die Zivilgesellschaft, will sich nicht gegen effiziente Strafverfolgung stellen, die müssen auch arbeiten können.
Aber wir haben als Zivilgesellschaft nicht die Verpflichtung, ihnen ihre Arbeit so trivial wie möglich zu machen, dass sie da beliebig Daten halten, sammeln und dann am Ende nur mit schlecht kalibrierter KI noch drüberfilzt oder so.
Ich glaube, man muss es aber auch noch ein bisschen öffnen, was wir, glaube ich, nicht
erahnt haben, als der Koalitionsvertrag geschlossen wurde, war, dass es auch noch auf der EU-Ebene
eine parallele Debatte um Massenüberwachung geben wird, nämlich die sogenannte Chat-Kontrolle.
Also es gibt ja auch noch, so zu sagen, eine zweite Ebene, die wir ganz stark debattieren,
die ja auch Formen von anlassloser Massenüberwachung sind. Nicht nur bei der Chat-Kontrolle, die sich mit Scannen von Nachrichten betrifft.
Man kann sagen, ich will es nur einmal so sagen, deutlich machen, das ist der andere
ganz große Punkt. Eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist ja dieses, wer mit wem wann und vielleicht
wo. Und jetzt reden wir über die andere Art von Überwachung, nämlich eine inhaltliche
Überwachung. Also auf die Inhalte, wo Menschen miteinander kommunizieren, zugreifen.
Richtig. Also wie massiv die gefordert wird, war glaube ich nicht absehbar zu Beginn der
Ampel. Und auch mit welcher Selbstverständlichkeit gefordert wird. Und es gibt aber auch noch
die Debatte um Körperdaten. Also um die Frage, inwieweit darf man auch vorratbiometrische
Daten erheben. Also diese Debatte findet auch noch zeitgleich statt.
Das kriegen wir jetzt von Kamera, Überwachung und öffentlichen Normen an.
Genau, das ist der sogenannte AI-Act. Also künstliche Intelligenz soll ja begrenzt werden und da gibt es einen großen Streit, ob da Körperdaten erfasst sind und wie.
Und es gibt sogar noch, wenn man so möchte, eine Form von, ja, also eine darüber liegende Debatte, ja, nämlich wie selbstverständlich das geworden ist, das festzuhalten.
Denn die Vorratsdatenspeicherung war immer ein Sinnbild für, ey wir packen mal alles auf einen Haufen. Und das hat sich sehr gewandelt. Es gibt noch einen vierten Bereich, den muss ich nur erwähnen, ohne dass wir ihn jetzt spezifizieren. Das sind Gesundheitsdaten.
Wir haben gleichzeitig noch eine Debatte mit dem europäischen Gesundheitsdatenraum, auf deutscher Ebene ebenfalls, wo diese Daten auch noch auf Vorrat gespeichert werden, Patientendaten.
Wir hätten nicht gedacht, dass es so massiv kommt. Ich jedenfalls nicht.
Aber um dann nochmal einen Schritt zurück zu gehen, hat sich die Ampelkoalition im Koalitionsvertrag
zu inhaltlicher digitalen Überwachung verhalten?
Ja, im Koalitionsvertrag ist diese Form von Scanning ganz klar ausgeschlossen.
Also Recht auf Verschlüsselung sozusagen. Genau, Recht auf Verschlüsselung steht explizit drin.
Und das ist natürlich überraschend, Ja, weil ...
Im Prinzip müssten wir hier einen riesen Koalitionsstreit haben, wie wir das etwa beim Heizhammer oder so gesehen haben, aber die Digitalpolitik…
Bitte nicht mit der Bildzeitung. Bitte lass diese eine Stelle in der Welt bildzeitungsfrei sein.
Ich sage es nur deshalb, weil das ein gesamtgesellschaftlicher Streit geworden ist.
Aber in der Digitalpolitik reicht es offenbar nicht, um das zum Spitzenpolitik-Thema zu machen.
Dass jetzt vielleicht auch selbst mal unser Bundeskanzler was dazu sagen würde, obwohl das ein massiver Konflikt ist.
Also im Koalitionsvertrag steht aber eigentlich drin, rechner Verschlüsselung, keine inhaltliche Überwachung und die EU sagt jetzt mit der Chatkontrolle, also ganz grob,
wollen wir vielleicht doch oder wollen wir vielleicht Anbieter verpflichten, dass die das machen müssen. Also irgendwie soll es dann halt doch gehen.
Das heißt, wenn die dem Koalitionsvertrag entsprechen würden, hätte sich die Ampelregierung gegenüber der EU auf die Hinterbeine stellen müssen und sagen, so nein, nicht mit uns.
Das hat sie auch. Wir sitzen ja heute, wir haben noch nicht das Datum gesagt, oder?
Heute ist der 27. September.
Es war nicht der 28.? Nein.
Heute wäre, heute oder morgen, bin jetzt gar nicht sicher, ob es der heutige Tag oder der morgige ist.
Gut, dass wir das Datum gesagt haben. Also nur, falls man Deutschland 2060 hört. Heute wäre der Tag gewesen, wo darüber in einem Ausschuss, der dafür zuständig ist oder mit zuständig ist, in Europa debattiert wird.
Die Bundesregierung hat schon durch ihr Verhalten ein Verschieben dieser Entscheidung bewirkt.
Also sie hat sich jetzt nicht so klar positioniert zu sagen, ey ne auf keinen Fall.
Aber so wie es jetzt im Entwurf der Verordnung steht, dann doch wieder nicht.
Also es gibt schon Streit drüber und Deutschland hat sich positioniert, praktisch.
Aber nicht so, dass diese Chat-Kontrolle jetzt geknickt wäre.
Die übrigens nicht nur Massenüberwachung enthält, sondern auch noch andere Probleme.
Aber wir haben ja dazu, haben wir dazu nicht ein Chaos-Radio gemacht?
Ich finde, ich finde… Ach nee, nee, wir haben dazu eine Sendung Dicke Bretter gemacht, die man ja nochmal anhören kann. Ah, mein Fehler.
Also quasi ja, dann Chaos, egal. Also könnt ihr im selben Feed hören, so rum.
Lisa, du hattest gerade aufgemerkt und das ein Gesichtsausdruck, der nahe liegt. Naja, also bitte hier.
Nein, nein, nein, volle Zustimmung. Ich glaube halt, was da total durchgesickert ist, ist so ein bisschen dieses komische Narrativ, das ja auf EU-Ebene voll verfangen hat, ist, wir müssen halt nur die Technik erfinden, um diese Inhalte zu scannen irgendwie, aber ohne die Verschlüsselung zu brechen. Also das ist eigentlich nur eine Frage der Innovation und des technologischen Fortschritts.
Und da haben sich ja alle den Mund fußlich geredet, dass das irgendwie nicht geht.
Und ich glaube, dass das aber schon intern, was ich so mitbekommen habe, immer noch irgendwie
dazu führt, dass diese Haltung so ein bisschen verfangen hat.
So ganz aus der Welt ist es ja nicht. Also weil die deutsche Position ja nicht so klar war von Anfang an, wie wir uns das erhofft hätten.
Vor allem nicht Misterienwald.
Du oder ihr würdest sagen, man würde das so interpretieren, dass man sagt, im Koalitionsvertrag steht Recht auf Verschlüsselung.
Die Regierung glaubt mittlerweile, weil sie dieses Narrativ glaubt, wir können sowohl den Koalitionsvertrag umsetzen, als auch die Inhalte scannen?
Ich glaube zumindest zeitweise hat dieses Narrativ verfangen. Ich glaube nicht, dass das weder in der Breite gewirkt hat, aber es war tatsächlich,
es ist so breit im europäischen Diskurs, dass es auch immer wieder auf der deutschen Ebene aufgeploppt ist.
Und da haben wir uns alle dem Mundfusselig geredet, dass das halt einfach Textsolutionismus ist vom Feinsteig.
Ich würde da gerne auf etwas hinweisen. Ich finde, da ist ein wichtiger Gedanke dabei, den wir, glaube ich, unbedingt herausstellen sollten.
Bei der Vorratsansprechung als Massenüberwachung. Da war schon klar, dass das technisch geht. Das war nicht wirklich umstritten.
Am Anfang, 2008 oder so, war schon mal eine Frage, schafft man das eigentlich bei den Daten?
Das ist ein zentraler Unterschied, den du auch gerade gesagt hast, zur Chat-Kontrolle. Da hat es so eine Art magische Technologie.
Und die gesamte, die gesamte IT-Welt redet sich seit Wochen und Monaten mundfustig, warum das so nicht geht, warum das auch eine inkompetente Lüge ist, zu sagen, das geht. Das hatten wir ganz selten.
Ähnlich ist es bei Biometriedaten oder Mustererkennung, zum Beispiel, wenn jemand irgendwo langläuft und so weiter. Da ist jetzt nicht ein technischer Konsens, dass das technisch geht, ja.
Und das unterscheidet die Debatte für mich sehr stark von den alten Debatten um Massenüberwachung.
Ähnliches könnte man sagen bei den Gesundheitsdaten. Da streiten sich auch viele Mediziner.
Gibt es eigentlich genügend Techniken, die das wirklich auch technisch sinnvoll machen,
von der ganzen Bevölkerung Patientendaten aufzunehmen und man kriegt da was Sinnvolles
forschungsmäßig raus?
Für mich unterscheidet sich das von früheren Debatten. Ich möchte gleich noch mal ganz kurz zu den Gesundheitsdaten kommen, aber ich sehe das
schon irgendwie so als zwei Kapitel der selben Geschichte, weil bei Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
Chatkontrolle und Biometriedaten würde ich sagen, da geht es ja tatsächlich um Überwachung.
Da geht es also darum, dass man sagt, man will die Bevölkerung überwachen, weil Straftaten verhindern.
Das ist ja sozusagen das Narrativ. Bei Gesundheitsdaten, deswegen würde ich ja gerne extra darüber sprechen, ist das
ja nicht sozusagen die Motivation. Also nicht dieser, wir wollen das machen, weil wir Schlimmes fänden wollen, sondern
da ist ja tatsächlich der Ausblick eher sozusagen, wir wollen das machen, weil uns das hilft,
Menschen gesund zu halten.
So. Aber. Nee, nee, nee. Stopp.
Nee, aber dann musst du mir schon erlauben, dem zu widersprechen. Gleich.
Wenn wir darüber reden. Weil jetzt möchte ich erstmal so sagen, diese, diese Dinger sozusagen, die angeblich
der Strafverfolgung sozusagen dienen sollen.
Wir haben jetzt schon über zwei Einzelne gesprochen, aber so im Großen und Ganzen,
Ist die Ampelregierung jemand, der sagt, also wir brauchen schon die bestmögliche digitale
Überwachung, die wir haben können und wir lassen uns nur sozusagen abkämpfen, dass es weniger ist?
Oder ist sie schon, zumindest im Grunde genommen, bemüht, auch...
Das Recht auf Privatsphäre und so weiter und so fort mitzudenken.
Ich glaube im Gesamten lassen sie es gerade erst mal laufen.
Wir haben jetzt den Blick auch nach Großbritannien, wo die Online Safety Bill gerade, nachdem
die Big Four gesagt haben, naja gut, dann bespielen wir euch nicht mehr.
Also Großbritannien hat ja gedroht, wenn wir nicht in alle eure Chats schon, also was
eigentlich Chatkontrolle gewesen wäre in der EU, haben sie jetzt da gesehen, dann wären
dann auch die großen Messenger-Anbieter da einfach rausgegangen, haben das ganz einfach
angesagt, können wir nicht umsetzen, geht technisch nicht. Und jetzt hat Großbritannien
ja angesagt, na gut, dann setzen wir es mal so lange nicht um, bis es da keine technischen
Möglichkeiten gibt. Und dieses Aussetzen, dieses Gefühl einfach mal zu sagen, wir schauen
erst mal, was da kommt, wir positionieren uns da außerdem, was wir hingeschrieben haben,
nicht weiter und halten uns da alle Optionen offen, um uns am Ende mit niemanden anzulegen,
sind die Vibes, die ich da gerade so aus der Koalition rauslesen würde.
Und deswegen ist es halt so wichtig, dass wir da auch weiter dranbleiben und dagegen stehen. Also das reine Moratorium hilft uns halt gar nicht. Im Gegenteil, da werden ja eher Zeitbomben in Gesetze gegossen, die in dem Moment hochgehen, wo irgendjemand mit seinen Wirtschaftsversprechen oder Lösungsversprechen irgendwie schlagkräftig genug ist, was halt bisher einfach nicht geschafft wurde.
Wenn KI-Blockchains dann endlich mächtig genug sind, um die Flugtaxis dahin zu...
Dann... Okay, also die...
Also wenn ich jetzt zusammenfassend versuchen würde zu sagen, die Ampelregierung arbeitet nicht konkret daran, Deutschland in einen digitalen Überwachungsstaat zu verwandeln, aber errichtet andererseits auch keine großen Bollwerke für die Leute, die das vielleicht versuchen wollen. Ist das so grob?
Na, wir können uns ja mal die Maßnahmen angucken, die sie eigentlich konkret vorgeschlagen haben im Koalitionsvertrag, ne.
Das Recht auf Verschlüsselung haben wir bisher noch nichts von gesehen.
Gibt's keinen Schritt in die Richtung. Es gibt kein Eckpunkte-Papier.
Wir hatten die Idee mit der Überwachungsgesamtrechtung. Ich muss kurz fragen. Recht auf Verschlüsselung, das wäre so zu sagen, also die Idee wäre, wenn es im Koalitionsvertrag steht,
muss es irgendwann ein Gesetz geben, wo dann drin steht, Menschen, haben das und so weiter.
Genau, genau. Das haben sie explizit so benannt. Wir führen ein Recht auf Verschlüsselung ein.
Aber passiert nichts. Bisher nicht passiert.
Verstanden. Der zweite Punkt war zum Beispiel auch potenziell ein Mittel, um Überwachung eher abzuwehren, war die Überwachungsgesamtrechnung.
Also die Idee mal zu evaluieren, auf welchen Ebenen und mit welchen Mitteln und aufgrund welcher Rechtsvorschriften sind eigentlich Menschen in diesem Lande von staatlicher Überwachung betroffen.
Die wurde jetzt im Frühjahr oder im Frühsommer ausgeschrieben, ist aber halt auch schon, wenn man so Vergabeverfahren kennt, mit nichts.
In dieser Legislatur, weil die Wissenschaftler müssen das doch erstmal darlegen, das ist
wirklich ein großes Feld, das wird noch eine große Studie.
Und es kam vor ein paar Tagen erst raus, die Freiheitskommission, das ist quasi ein Expertengremium,
das die Bewachungsgesamtrechnung und auch andere solche Maßnahmen mit begleiten soll,
also extern evaluieren soll und die soll 2025, also mitten im Wahlkampf eigentlich, ihre Arbeit aufnehmen.
Das wird in dieser Legislatur nicht passieren. Das kannst du abhacken.
Aha, okay, das könnte also klappen, wenn dieselbe Regierung, naja gut. Das hoffen wir mal. So, jetzt zu den Gesundheitsdaten. Das ist ja sozusagen die Perspektive, die es für mich hat, das ist halt was, wo es halt nicht darum geht, Leute zu verfolgen, sondern da gibt es eher eine andere Motivation in meinem Verständnis, nämlich die Annahme, dass man über einen großen Haufen von Gesundheitsdaten gut forschen kann, aber du willst widersprechen, Konz.
Ja, ich beobachte da einfach einen Sinneswandel, ähnlich wie man das bei fundamentalen Fragen wie bei der Chatkontrolle sieht.
Also zerstöre ich zum Beispiel irgendeine Form von technischer Sicherheit, um scannen zu können.
Man wird ähnliche Tendenzen nach der Pandemie an Gesundheitsdaten in der Argumentation erfahren, nämlich zu sagen, hör mal zu.
Unabhängig davon, was ein Individuum mit seinen Krankheiten, mit seinen physischen und psychischen Zuständen denkt darüber,
erwarten wir, dass die gesamte Bevölkerung zur Verfügung steht, um solchen Bedrohungen, wie wir sie in der Pandemie gesehen haben, zu begegnen.
Und also, dass sich nicht Einzelne hinstellen können und sagen, okay, also ich habe bestimmte Krankheiten, damit verbinden sich vielleicht Stigmata,
ich möchte nicht in diese Datensammlung, dass das auf eine Weise abqualifiziert wird, so nach dem Motto, ja, dann verhinderst du Forschung,
dann verhinderst du Fortschritt in der Gesundheit.
Also da hat sich, ich schiebe das auf die Pandemie, weil ich es mir nicht anders erklären kann,
da hat sich was verschoben.
Und das unterscheidet sich für mich nicht so stark von den klassischen Strafverfolgungsargumentationen,
weil das wird dann sehr schnell sehr holistisch.
Und die, die sich dagegen wehren, dass man das anlasslos wegspeichert,
sozusagen werden so ein bisschen reduziert auf, ja klar, da gibt es Grundrechte,
Aber es gibt ja quasi höherringige Ziele und da sehe ich einfach den Zusammenhang und das war mir früher überhaupt nicht begegnet.
Gesundheitsdaten waren immer klarer als sensibler als andere Daten gesehen und da hat sich...
Ich möchte noch kurz fragen, Stand der Dinge ist doch aber alles, was momentan mit elektronischer
Patientenakte gemacht wird, ist Opt-in.
Nein, wir haben ein Forschungsdatenzentrum in Deutschland und alle gesetzlich Versicherten müssen dort, alle Patientendaten der gesetzlich Versicherten, nicht jedoch der Privatversicherten, landen da. Aber dieses Forschungsdatenzentrum ist aktuell noch nicht so wirklich arbeitend, speichert nur, weil die IT-Landschaft ist noch nicht fertig und sie haben kein ordentliches IT-Sicherheitskonzept.
Aber dazu haben wir tatsächlich eine eigene Chaos-Radio-Sendung gemacht. Also wer möchte, kann sich über die Gesundheitsdaten informieren. Und die europäische Debatte läuft quasi parallel. Auch da ist die Frage, opt-in oder opt-out. Das ist dieses sogenannte europäische Gesundheitsdatenzentrum.
Aber eine Sache, die sich gerade auf nationale, auf deutscher Ebene verschoben hat nochmal, die ich auch ganz spannend finde, ist ja die Erweiterung der Datenvorhaltung, also der Datenspeicherung, die jetzt bei dem neuen Gesundheitsdatennutzungsgesetz auf 100 Jahre hochgesetzt wird. Zentraler Speicher, 100 Jahre. Ihr seid die Experten, ist das in irgendeiner Form IT-sicherheitsmäßig gewährleistet?
Da stellen sich die Sicherheitsfragen, aber auch die klassischen Grundrechtsfragen.
Und selbstverständlich ist die Debatte auch schon an genetische Daten abgebogen.
Ich glaube auch, diese Tatsache, die wir noch bei der Vorzeitenspeicherung debattiert haben,
ist es überhaupt möglich von den Datenmengen, als hätte es sich ja nicht erübrigt.
Weil möglich ist es. Ich sehe das schon als eine Form von Dammbruch, die aber silently ist.
Es wird nicht wirklich debattiert.
Es gibt für diese digitalen Fragen, gerade so bei anlasslosen Sachen, wenig Unterstützung, also politischer Art meine ich jetzt.
Ich sehe es schon ein bisschen anders, als ich das eben beschrieben habe in unserem Justizministerium.
Ich habe schon den Eindruck, dass der Justizminister Buschmann auch sehr, auch schon prinzipiell sehr grundrechteorientiert ist,
Aber innerhalb der Ampel hat er glaube ich wenig Macht.
Das heißt, Überwachung bekommt in der Ampel welche Note? Oh, ich wäre komplett durchgefallen, bin ich überhaupt total unzufrieden, weil wir hätten immer noch das Voraussetzungsspeicherungsgesetz, wenn sie nicht das Ölzeug kassiert hätten. Also, ne, bin ich unzufrieden.
Gegenstimmen? Also, bei der 4 wäre ich schon mit dabei, komplett durchgefallen, weiß ich nicht, was das denn bei Konz bedeutet.
Durchgefallen, durchgefallen, durchgefallen. Sind wir also jetzt bei 5? Elisa, möchtest du noch?
Na? Ja, ich müsste da auch eine Fünf geben, einfach aufgrund der Arbeitsverweigerungshaltung auch. Also das ist nicht ausreichend.
Okay, gut. So, sieht nicht so gut aus, liebe Ambulanzistin. Jetzt kommt die Sicherheit, jetzt wird's hart.
Jetzt kommt das nächste Thema, das ist ja, also die, wenn wir dann schon Internet haben und da drin auch unsere Daten, die mehr oder weniger sicher sind, vor der Überwachung des Staates, ist ja dann noch die Frage, wie ist das denn jetzt mit,
Und das ist auch so ein Thema, wo ich mich ein bisschen fürchte davor, das in zehn Minuten durchzukauen, weil IT-Sicherheit ist ja so mega groß.
Das fängt ja an bei, soll der Staat Rechner hacken dürfen bei der Strafverfolgung?
Bis hin zu, wie schnell muss wer welche Sicherheitslücken an wen melden?
Haben VerbraucherInnen Anspruch auf standeszeitgemäße IT-Security der Geräte, die sie kaufen. Wo wollt ihr denn anfangen in diesem riesigen Feld?
Ah, du hast die Geheimdienste vergessen. Die Geheimdienste, die sind ja so geheim, da hab ich die gar nicht gesehen.
Naja, ich glaub wir könnten erstmal damit anfangen. Was steht drin? Was haben sie uns versprochen?
Da haben sie uns eine IT-sichere Welt, eine IT-Security-Welt versprochen.
Ein wirksames Schwachstellenmanagement. Ein wirksames Schwachstellenmanagement.
Das steht im Koalitionsvertrag. Da steht auch drin, was damit gemeint ist.
Wenn ich einen Heißluftballon gehört habe, dann...
Aber Sie fügen immerhin den Qualificato hinzu, ein wirksames Schwachstellenmanagement mit dem Ziel,
Sicherheitslücken zu schließen.
Das ist ja auch schon mal gut, das noch mal so explizit hinzusetzen.
Ja, okay. Sie sammeln die Schwachstellen nicht nur, um sie auszunutzen und Leute zu überwachen, sondern wir wollen sie schließen.
Das hört sich doch schon mal nach einem Versprechen an. Ja, das hat uns alle sehr gefreut.
Also ich gehe davon aus, es gibt jetzt sozusagen nach zwei Jahren noch so eine Art Produkthaftungsgesetz,
wo die Hersteller dazu gezwungen sind, Schwachstellen öffentlich und transparent zu melden und
sofort zu schließen, ja?
Ne, das kommt jetzt erst langsam mit dem Cyber Resilience Act, aber auch aus der EU wieder zurück.
Also die Ampel war nicht tätig?
Da war die Ampel nicht tätig, auch wenn… Ich würde da einen größeren Bogen spannen,
Weil dort irgendwie auf Seite 16 in dem Koalitionsvertrag stand quasi von der Formulierungshilfe, die
der CCC dort 2021 abgegeben hat, kurz, da standen echt ganze Absätze, also wie im Schulunterricht
vom Nachbarn noch mit die Werbung umgestellt, dass es nicht ganz auffällt, aber da waren
einige Dinge, wo du boah, haben wir gedacht, hat sich rausgestellt, das haben sie auch
ganz weit nach oben gepackt.
Ich glaube, sie wollten dort Dinge, die einfach bei denen soweit konsensfähig sind in allen
drei Parteien und so ein bisschen Kit in den weiter schwierigen Punkten weiter unten, wollten
es aber dann ganz oben etwas, was nach Zukunft klingt, schon gleich reintun und haben gesagt,
oh, da hat die CCC was geschrieben, das nehmen wir mal rein, kann jemand überprüfen, ob
was umgesetzt, nee, interessiert am Ende eh keinen und dann machen wir mal sowas wie.
Am Anfang zehn Seiten und schreiben das ab und da standen dann auch viele Dinge drin
und dann, der CCC genauso hätte da reinschreiben können, aber es standen dann weiter unten,
die FDP mitschreiben durfte, auch so Warnsignale sind viel wichtiger,
sind Investitionen in künstliche Intelligenz, Quantentechnologie, Cyber Security, DLT,
also Distributed Ledger, also sprich Blockchains.
Also liebe Leute, wir müssen an dieser Stelle vielleicht so ein paar Begriffe
können wir nicht von Anfang an erklären, weil wenn man die von Anfang an erklärt,
dann kommt man in eine Teufelsküche.
Blockchain ist ein solcher Begriff, aber es gibt ein reichhaltiges Chaos-Radioarchiv, tut euch da bitte um.
Also ich mache jetzt mal so eine ganz grobe Zusammenfassung.
Das ist Quatsch. So, haben wir zusammengefasst. Das heißt, dass wir uns zwar da, wo wir als erstes drüber gelesen haben,
die Platze gefreut haben.
Und einige haben dann aufgehört, da durchzuscrollen. Und dann am Ende durften dann auch die weniger nachhaltigen
und weniger sinnvollen Technologiebereiche mit in den Koalitionsvertrag da reingeschrieben werden.
Sodass das ungefähr auch widerspiegelt, wie ernst sie es dann an der Stelle gemeint haben.
Das heißt, die Zukunftspolitiker aus der FDP wollten dann genau so Dinge reinschreiben, wie wahrscheinlich die…
Also verstehe ich das richtig, im Koalitionsvertrag ist der Abschnitt zu IT-Security so ein Tummelplatz von jeder darf mal?
Das sah so aus, ja.
Also das muss man, glaube ich, auch ein bisschen einsortieren.
IT-Sicherheit ist so ein Massenproblem geworden.
Das betrifft Unternehmen, das betrifft Behörden in hohem Maße, das betrifft die Regierung selbst, das ist ja auch die Ampel, die angetreten ist nach dem Bundestagshack und so weiter.
Sie hatten einen fetten Skandal an der Backe, nämlich die Pegasus-Veröffentlichung. Sie wissen, dass es eine ganze Branche gibt, die sich einen Wolf hackt und sich demontiert.
Kannst du nochmal kurz Pegasus-Veröffentlichung?
Man muss mal den Hintergrund sehen. Kannst du nochmal kurz Pegasus-Veröffentlichung?
Die Pegasus Veröffentlichungen betreffen eine ganze Branche, die Überwachungs- und Hackingsoftware anbietet und ein großes internationales Medienkonsortium hat sich mit diesem Pegasus Project zusammengetan, um diese Branche zu beleuchten, insbesondere den israelischen Part davon, die sogenannte NSO Group spielt da eine große Rolle und der Trojaner davon heißt Pegasus, deswegen heißt das Pegasus Project. Dazu haben wir ein eigenes Karus Radio gebaut.
So sieht das aus. Also ich meine, da ist halt einfach viel passiert, finde ich.
Also IT-Sicherheit ist ja so ein Querschnittthema, weil wenn du irgendwie plötzlich Digitalisierung
überall hast, dann ist auch Sicherheit in der Digitalisierung plötzlich ein Querschnittthema
überall, wie du es ja schon eingangs angekündigt hast.
Das kann man jetzt alles zusammenwerfen, aber genauso wie Sicherheit und Safety im öffentlichen Raum.
Also du hast ja in vielen anderen Gewerken, gibt's ja Bauaufsicht für die Häuser, die
irgendwie sowas wie Sicherheit der Bürgerinnen in den Häusern hat, irgendwie wie Lebensmittelaussicht.
Hast du dort viele Themen, die in der realen Weltsicherheit beschrieben haben, die du jetzt auch wieder findest, wo das Digitale plötzlich ubiquitär wird, also sich überall, ne?
Ich möchte eine Diskussion rausgreifen, die wir in der Vergangenheit immer wieder geführt haben, also auch hier im Chaos Radio, und das ist die, wo ich glaube, dass BSI eine zentrale Rolle spielt.
Also es gibt, oder war das der andere Laden, dessen Namen ich schon wieder vergessen habe? Schönbohm?
Ne, ne. Zitis? Vielleicht. Also das Ding war immer folgende. Es gab immer die Idee, Technologie, die eben sozusagen weit verbreitet ist, da muss ein wirksames Schwachstellenmanagement mit dem Ziel Sicherheitslücken zu lösen. Das brauchen wir. Das ist schon lange eine ExpertInnenforderung.
Und da war die Idee, vielleicht gibt es eine staatliche Institution, die das managen könnte.
Und dann war aber immer sozusagen der Verdacht dahinter, naja gut, aber der Staat ist auch
der, der möglicherweise Schwachstellen haben will.
Um sie vorzuhalten, um dann irgendwo einbrechen zu können. Also bei den großen bösen Endbossen ins Gerät oder vielleicht auch bei den Drogenhändlern.
Da müssen wir so gucken, wo man den Staat zur Hand nehmen kann.
Oder bei den letzten Generationen. Oder bei den letzten Generationen.
Meine Frage bezieht sich jetzt darauf, in dieser Diskrepanz, wenn man es ganz diplomatisch
formulieren würde, Rechtsgüterabwägung, ist da was passiert?
Nee, kann man so nicht sagen. Es gibt einen Gesetzentwurf, der die staatsreale Nutzung
ein bisschen beschränken will, was sie auch versprochen haben. Der ist aber noch nicht
durch. Also wo sie die Möglichkeiten, also sozusagen die formalen rechtlichen Befugnisse,
wann man hacken darf als Staat, einschränken wollen. Das ist uns natürlich zu wenig. Das
Schwachstellenmanagement, das schon erwähnte, ist bisher einfach nicht da. Es gibt immer
noch keine Regeln für die Behörden, wenn sie von Schwachstellen erfahren, wie sie damit
Die sehen sich da schon in der Aufgabe, also das BSI betreibt dieses Zertbund und ist dort...
Was ist das Zertbund? Das wollte ich gerade erzählen, das ist das BSI, sorgt dafür, sammelt irgendwie von den
einschlägigen Mailinglisten und irgendwie von Foren dort die CV, also die...
Fachstellen. Die Fachstellenbeschreibung ein, gibt Empfehlungen, welche jetzt den Administratoren auch mal
ein Wochenende kosten sollte oder wo man bis zum nächsten Dienstag warten kann mit dem
einspielen. Das heißt, diese Verwaltung, diese industriekonforme Verwaltung von
Schwachstellen, die hat da schon, die gibt es auch schon eine Weile.
Die ist vor der Ampel schon entstanden. Genau, das ist keine Heldentat der Koalition.
Das ist quasi dieses Schwachstellenmanagement, was das Bund anbietet,
der Zivilgesellschaft und der Industrie.
Das ist aber nicht gemeint im Koalitionsvertrag. Dieses Schwachstellenmanagement
Das meint, was andere, das meint, was normale westliche moderne Staaten haben.
Nämlich, dass sie Regeln haben, bei bestimmter Kritikalität von Sicherheitslücken, dass
sie den Behörden vorschreiben, wie sie damit umzugehen haben, welche müssen sie melden und welche nicht.
Die USA sind dafür das Vorbild, die das ein Jahrzehnt lang haben und das fehlt bei uns
immer noch. Das hat es damit gemeint.
Aber selbstverständlich. Dann sag's, sprich's aus.
Das, was ich eben beschrieben habe, ist quasi im Handbuch von Schwachstellenmanagement.
Es gibt das Open Vulnerability Assessment System. Ja, selbstverständlich.
Das ist genau das. aber Behörden ja auch binden.
Ja, tut es doch auch. Das sind die Schwachstellen, die müsst ihr, wenn ihr euch irgendwie zertifizieren lasst, dann müsst ihr genau diese gemeldeten Schwachstellen, von uns gemeldeten Schwachstellen, binnen dieser Zeit einspielen oder die Fixes dafür einspielen.
Das ist quasi behördlich geregelt und muss wie nach dem Grundschutzhandbuch auch so implementiert sein, dass man als Behörde und als…
Ich höre gerade, dass ihr jetzt über zwei verschiedene Dinge redet, nämlich, dass du darüber redest, Erdgeist, dass die Behörden sozusagen Firmen dazu auffordert, auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise mit Sicherheitslücken umzugehen.
Und Cons höre ich, dass ihr darüber redet, dass es auch gesetzlich geregelt sein muss, wie die Behörden selbst, also wie der Staat selbst mit den Sicherheitslücken umgeht.
Präzise, aber Schwachstellenmanagement hat irgendwie eine Bedeutung und das ist eigentlich die, dass es Prozesse gibt, wie man mit gemeldeten Schwachstellen umgeht, als Gesellschaft und als Industrie und als Behörden.
Und dann natürlich gibt es die Betrachtung, wenn das BSI dem BMI unterstellt ist und das BMI sagt, sag mal, du kannst nicht die einmal abfallen lassen, könnte man nicht ausnahmsweise mal ein Auge zudrücken oder sogar reinschreiben,
Ihr müsst besonders interessante für uns mal nicht gefixt lassen, damit wir sie weiter benutzen können, wenn jemand bei euch vorbeikommt und die meldet.
Das ist ein Teil des Schwachstellenmanagements. Du musst eine Bindung haben.
Was wir uns vorstellen und schon lange fordern ist, dass sich Behörden an bestimmte Regeln dieses Schwachstellenmanagement binden müssen.
Und das betrifft nun mal genau das Hacking.
Also den Einsatz von Hackingsoftware. Auch beim, nicht nur bei der Eigenentwicklung, sondern auch beim Kauf der Formate.
Das ist aber schon wieder viel zu speziell, wenn wir nicht erst mal die Basis haben, wie
wir damit umgehen, wie formalisiert irgendjemand nachgucken kann, ob die Softwarekomponente,
ob es da vielleicht eine Einsatzempfehlung gibt für einen bestimmten Versionsstand einer.
Software.
Das sind ja erst mal die Basics. Das ist aber exakt die Frage, die ich gestellt habe.
Die Frage, die ich gestellt habe, ist genau, wie ist diese Diskrepanz geklärt zwischen
der Starter Zugriff auf Sicherheitslücken, die er missbrauchen könnte und wie sicher
können wir sein, dass er das nicht tut?
Genau, und da sind wir jetzt gerade in der spannenden Phase, dass jetzt auch gerade wieder
das BSI aus der, aus dem BMI rausgenommen werden soll, gibt es glaube ich morgen oder
Ende September, Anfang Oktober.
Gibt es gerade wieder innerhalb der Koalition wieder Gespräche und Geschache, ob das stattfindet.
Dann wäre uns auch gleich viel wohler, weil dann könnte eben nicht das BMI auf dem kurzen
Dienstweg seiner unterstellten Behörde mal was ansagen, was sie jetzt gerade wollten
für einen befreundeten Dienst, dann wäre uns schon besser.
Und dann, wenn Sie das wirklich so durchzögen, dann wäre mir auch das Zeugnis in dem Bereich für die Koalition
eine Note besser wert. Jawohl, es ist noch nicht passiert. Es ist noch nicht passiert.
Okay, also. Note?
Ich finde es sehr enttäuschend. Es gibt eine vier von mir. Aber auch nur deshalb, weil sie auch Urteile kassiert haben.
Bei den Staatsräumen ist ja nicht nur die sozusagen Gesetzgebung,
sondern eben auch, was etwa im Europäischen Parlament passiert,
was bei den Gerichten passiert, mit einzubeziehen. Ich bin da sehr unzufrieden.
Okay. Lisa?
Ich möchte noch einen totalen Tropfen auf dem heißen Stein einstreuen.
Nämlich, ja, zu dem allen und dass da nichts passiert ist. Also es ist eine Sache passiert, wo ich gar nicht weiß, ob das wirklich so eine interne Entscheidung war oder ob das eher von außen herangetragen wurde.
Es gibt eine Art von Bug Bounty Programm, das im Rahmen des Sovereign Tech Funds, also dieses Förderprogramms für letztendlich Bausteine, Implementierungen von Protokollen, die wichtig sind für die wirklich grundlegenden Funktionsweisen heutiger Technologien.
Die fördern einmal die Entwicklung, aber sie fördern jetzt zusätzlich auch das Melden und Beheben von Sicherheitslücken. Das ist konkret motiviert aus dieser Lock4J-Debatte.
Es ist motiviert aus welcher Debatte?
Das könnt ihr wahrscheinlich besser erklären als ich. Naja, manchmal haben Sicherheitslücken, die sehr viele Systeme betreffen. Also wo jetzt hunderte und tausende Admins ihre Wochenende mitverbringen, haben halt auch politische Folgen.
Und ich weiß nicht genau, ob wir tatsächlich diese spezielle Bug bounty-Programm, also die Idee, wir zahlen Geld dafür, wenn jemand uns...
Stopp, stopp, stopp. Erstmal, was war Log4J?
Log4J ist eine Bibliothek für die Programmiersprache Java, in der ziemlich viele Softwareprojekte ihr Logging, also ihr während des Betriebes wegschreiben von Zeilen, wo die Software grob erklärt, was sie gerade tut, um besondere Ereignisse, die ihnen begegnet, zu loggen, damit später Administratoren oder Entwicklerinnen nachgucken können, was da eigentlich passiert ist.
Und diese Software-Komponente hatte eine trivial ausnutzbare Schwachstelle, die man dann von.
Draußen durch das Bespielen der Java-Software, die so Requests von Browsern entgegengenommen
hat, wenn man dort einige Werte besonders lustig formatiert hat, dann hat diese Logging-Komponente
im Hintergrund lustige Dinge gemacht, wo im Folge dessen das System quasi von Ferne übernommen werden konnte.
Und da diese Komponente so eine ziemlich kleine und von allem weit verbreitet, hat quasi jeder, der ein Java-Projekt irgendwo betrieben hat, mit wenigen Ausnahmen, hat diese Log4j-Komponente im Laufe der Zeit irgendwo reingezogen.
Und damit war dann plötzlich von einem Tag auf den nächsten, als diese Schwachstelle bekannt wurde, hat sich rausgestellt, dass dieses Projekt zwar von allen benutzt wird, aber sehr wenig Liebe erfährt, weil so eine Logging-Komponente zu schreiben ist jetzt auch nicht vergnügungssteuerpflichtig.
So, dass dann offenbar wurde, dass dieses Kartenhaus manchmal auch mit den dünnsten
Karten unten zuerst gebaut wurde, auf dem quasi unser ganzes modernes Internet Psch.
Und die Idee sozusagen des Sovereign Tech Fund ist, in Zukunft zahlen wir Menschen,
die solche Dinge entdecken, in solcher wichtigen Software ein Extrageld, also ein Kopfgeld quasi.
Also der STF, dieser Sovereign Tech Fund ist ja explizit angetreten, solche Komponenten
in der Zukunft zu identifizieren, bevor es brennt.
Jetzt herzugehen und sagen, gibt es noch andere Softwarekomponenten, die vor 30 Jahren mal
geschrieben wurden, wo der Programmierer längst in Rente gegangen ist, wo auch noch du ein
ähnliches Setting hast, dass diese Komponente da draußen so weit verbreitet ist und die
wenigsten Leute das wissen und die wenigsten, die es benutzen, auch noch Lust haben, sich
daran zu beteiligen, es weiter zu pflegen, wo dann quasi der Staat begriffen hat, das
ist irgendwie auch kritische Infrastruktur, sowas irgendwie am Leben zu halten, er kostet
nicht viel Geld und da kann man mal staatliche Mittel draufwerfen, um dann einen Programmierer-Stamm
zu beschäftigen, der diese kritische Infrastruktur pflegt und dokumentiert, nach Schwachstellen
durchsucht, sie fixt, um generell...
Nicht nur kritische Infrastruktur, es sind auch teilweise Komponenten, die man jetzt
nicht klassischerweise, also rechtlich so definieren würde, die aber eben einfach viel
benutzt sind und so eine Art Botte, wie so ein Flaschenhals sind.
Also die Idee ist toll, aber ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir die, der Ampel, also könnt ihr mir sagen, ja, da ist die irgendwie…
Hat er die Vorgängerregierung angesprochen? Eigentlich schon. Okay.
Aber nicht wohl dieses Bug-Bounty-Programm, das wurde ja nachgeladen. Okay.
Aber die Frage ist natürlich, die Ampel könnte das ja jetzt verstetigen und könnte sich dazu irgendwie committen, das hab ich bisher jetzt so auch noch nicht gehört, ich weiß nicht, ob das im Hintergrund der Fall ist.
Und das ist so eine langjährige Forderung.
Die Aktion irgendwie an Menschen mit Tech-Kompetenz da draußen aus, die sich halt irgendwie engagieren
und dann kriegen die ein Schmerzensgeld für die Abend- und Nacht- und Wochenendschichten,
die sie dann da machen. Eigene Aktion hätte ich lieber gesehen. Also 4 plus?
Ja. Nee, komm, wir haben mal ein Beispiel. Wir haben mal ein positives Beispiel. Ist auch mal was, oder?
Ja, ich bin hier für die positive Haltungsgeschichte.
Ich hab ganz große Bauchschmerzen, weil, wie wir haben ja eingangs gesagt, das große Thema in DC halt,
ist so umgreifend und jetzt nur daran festzumachen, dass IT-Sicherheit, wo sie aktiv und dominiert
wird bei den Geheimdiensten, ist jetzt für mich nicht mein primärer Zensurmaßstab,
würde ich sagen.
Deswegen, wie jetzt ein bisschen das zusammen zu zurren, wäre unsachlich fürchtig. Ich hab was.
Wir haben doch jetzt über sehr viele Komponenten gesprochen.
Ja, ja, genau. Aber das ist jetzt nur daran aufzuhören. Du sollst einfach eine Note vergeben.
Ich würde irgendwie schon sagen, eine 3. Weil?
Weil sie viel begriffen haben, viel stand im Koalitionsvertrag drin, die Mittel fließen.
Das hört sich ein bisschen nach bestens bemüht an.
Da kommst du, ich will ja nicht vorgreifen, das ist aber ein Problem.
Wir haben irgendwie mit dem ITZ-Bund, haben wir quasi eine Behörde, die an vielen Stellen
auch mit ziemlich prozessualer Präzision.
Du, Edgars, du sollst jetzt eine Note vergeben und grob sagen, warum, jetzt musst du schon
wieder erklären, was ist ITZ Bund?
Das ist genau das Problem, das ist choreografisch gerade ein bisschen schwierig, das käme erst
später. Aber das ist ja für die digitale Souveränität, wurde ja den Behörden angeboten.
Die was? Du machst es einfach nicht besser.
Digitale Souveränität, an der Stelle heißt grob, wir gehen nicht und nehmen die Google-Rechenzentren,
die Behörden-IT abzufeiern, sondern bauen unser eigenes Rechenzentrum dahin. Sie nennen es Klaudifizieren, was ich ganz drollig fand und haben damit dann das...
Aber das hat doch jetzt überhaupt gar nichts mit IT-Sicherheit zu tun.
Natürlich hat das mit IT-Sicherheit zu tun. Naja, so am Rande, aber jetzt nicht so direkt.
Naja... Also man möchte schon IT-Sicherheit und sein vom Bund betriebenen Rechenzentrum.
Ja, ob das dann sozusagen ein Fortschritt ist, I don't know. Also wir bleiben jetzt mal bei drei. Wenn man das alles zusammenrechnet, drei minus sind wir wieder da.
Wir könnten noch rüber schlenzen zum ITZ, also die Frage, welche Dienstleistungen man anbietet, wie unabhängig man sein will, von wem, wie nachhaltig vielleicht auch. Wollen wir nicht gleich anschließen? Können wir doch machen, oder?
Da kommen wir auch zur Digitalisierung der Verwaltung. Genau.
Das wäre der nächste Punkt. Beim Digitalen reden wir immer über die Dinge, die wehtun, Überwachung, Sicherheitslücken
usw.
Aber wenn man das Ganze von einer anderen Ecke angeht, wie schaffen wir eine digitale
Welt, vielleicht einen digitalen Staat, wo man nicht nur einmal am Feuer löschen ist,
dann ist es sozusagen, man macht ein paar Sachen richtig.
Und da gibt es so zwei Grundforderungen. die jetzt, ich weiß, dass das sozusagen waghalsig ist, aber ich würde es trotzdem sozusagen
versuchen, weil es im weitesten Sinne sozusagen ein Vorausdenken einer digitalen staatlichen Struktur ist.
Das eine ist, es gibt so eine Forderung, der Staat soll Software verwenden, die Open-Source
ist oder selbstgemacht, am besten beides und das andere ist sozusagen die Verwaltung, also
die Infrastruktur des Staates, die vor allen Dingen dafür zuständig ist, dass die Bürger
Kontakt zum Staat halten können, soll digitalisiert werden.
Das wiederum am besten durch Open-Source-Software und so weiter und so fort, also deswegen sozusagen so grob ein Gebiet.
Im Koalitionsvertrag steht dazu explizit, Entwicklungsaufträge werden in der Regel als Open-Source beauftragt.
Die entsprechende Software wird grundsätzlich öffentlich gemacht.
Das klingt doch fantastisch.
Klingt fantastisch und das sehen wir an einigen Stellen auch.
Auf der anderen Seite haben wir auch so SAP-Komponenten, die der Staat für die interne Beschaffung
da baut, die dann nicht Open Source sind.
Gerade noch ein Mixed-Back, wo ich noch nicht mal jetzt zu einem finalen Urteil, nicht mal
zum Halbjahresurteil gekommen bin.
Wir haben diesen ganzen Bereich des Online-Zugangsgesetzes, wo es jetzt ein Online-Zugangsgesetz 2.0 gibt,
wo es eher um die klassische Verwaltungsdigitalisierung geht und diese...
Ja diese ganzen Schmerzen, die Leute, also Privatleute haben, aber auch Unternehmen, wenn sie irgendetwas Digitales mit diesem Staat machen wollen. Also für mich hat das einen gewissen Zusammenhang zur IT-Sicherheit. Diese IT-Sicherheitsdebatten sind mittlerweile wirklich, also die sind einfach teuer, die sind problembeladen und so ähnlich haben wir das in der Verwaltungsdigitalisierung.
Es ist für Privatleute und für die Wirtschaft mittlerweile wirklich ein absoluter Hemmschuh, in welchem Zustand sich Deutschland da befindet.
Beim OZG, jetzt OZG 2.0, das Onlinezugangsgesetz, da hat sich nicht viel zum Guten gewandelt.
Sie schaffen nicht, auch nicht jetzt nach einer halben Legislaturperiode, da mehr an den Start zu bringen, wo wirklich jetzt Leute sagen, jetzt klappt das mal. Wir sind nicht mehr dritte Welt, was Digitalisierung angeht. Ich finde das ganz schlimm. Ich bin enttäuscht. Die DZ sehe ich ein bisschen anders, aber dazu wird Edgar jetzt bestimmt vielleicht was sagen.
Diese ganzen Akronyme, OZG und so weiter, das sind ja aber auch Dinge, und ich glaube, da liegt echt der Hund begraben, die seit Jahren schon auf dem Weg sind, also die auch tatsächlich die Arbeit dieser Koalition, denen lange voranstehen schon und quasi da auf den Weg gebracht wurden.
Da waren natürlich auch ein paar Parteien mit drin, die jetzt auch an der Regierung sind.
Aber ...
Ich glaube tatsächlich, dass das auch so ein strukturelles Problem ist, dass die Verwaltung da einfach ganz andere Zyklen hat irgendwie. Und dann ist politischer Wille zwar vielleicht irgendwie da, aber in der Umsetzung passiert da total wenig. Und da dann nochmal Impulse reinzugeben ist super schwer.
Aber ist der politische Wille da, würdest du sagen?
Auch hier wieder mit der Koalition schwierig to be debated. Wir hatten zumindest nochmal eine Debatte über zum Beispiel jetzt bei der Registermodernisierung über die Steuer-ID. Also die Registermodernisierung ist, wie ich finde, ein generell nicht unsinnvolles Vorhaben. Verwaltungen haben unterschiedliche Datenbestände. Zum Beispiel wer Elterngeld kriegt, wer Waffe kriegt, all diese Geschichten.
Und überall geben wir immer wieder unsere Daten rein, dabei passieren Fehler, Übertragungsfehler. Wir müssen dauernd irgendwie wieder neue Papiere ausfüllen. Ich glaube, diese Stapel von Papiere, die man zehnmal ausfüllen muss, die kennen wir alle und kennen diesen Schmerz.
Oder man muss da hin.
Und man muss da hin. Also alles. Oder man kriegt irgendwas nicht, weil irgendwas falsch ausgefüllt war, obwohl die Daten schon zehnmal abgegeben wurden. Auf Papier.
Und da ist jetzt also die Idee, einen Mechanismus zu finden, eine Art von Datenabgleich in der Verwaltung, eine Art Source of Truth am Ende zu entwickeln, damit wir nicht dauernd wieder irgendwie da formularisieren müssen.
Das ist erstmal wichtig und ist eine Grundvoraussetzung für alles, was dann so an Anwendungen wie digitales Elterngeld beantragen, keine Ahnung, eine bessere Art und Weise die Energiepauschale zu beantragen für Studierende.
Das wäre so quasi der Basislayer, der da gerade entstehen soll, seit x-tausend Jahren.
Das ist erstmal sinnvoll.
Es war jetzt die Frage, jetzt haben wir da irgendwie die Daten von Menschen, personenbezogene Daten,
dann wo natürlich auch total viel getrackt wird und letztendlich Information aufläuft,
die hochschwierig ist und auch hochsensibel ist.
Und wie speichern wir die weg, aber auch quasi fühlen wir da jetzt Datensätze komplett zusammen? Gibt's Möglichkeiten, das irgendwie verteilt zu lassen und immer nur punktuell abzufragen? Wie machen wir dieses ganze Datenmanagement da drin? Und vor allem, was ist denn eigentlich eine Art von Identifier?
Also und die haben da glaube ich ein relativ altes Datenbankmodell im Kopf, dass sie quasi sagen, einmal braucht ihr so eine Art Key-Value, einmal braucht ihr so eine Art Schlüssel, über den wir das alles abrufen.
Und da war schon in der letzten Legislatur der Vorschlag, das über diese neu eingeführte Steuer-ID zu machen, obwohl bei deren Einführung…
Naja, neu, die ist ja schon wieder zehn Jahre alt.
Genau, genau. Also neu. Verwaltungsdenken war das gestern, glaube ich. Und da, als die eingeführt wurde, wurde das eigentlich, zumindest verbal, explizit ausgeschlossen, dass dieser Unique Identifier ja auch auf andere Bereiche übertragen wird.
Jetzt haben wir den Salat, sie wollen es doch machen. Und da gab es zumindest in
der Koalition, um auf eine Frage zurückzukommen, wie die Arbeit da jetzt so
gerettet ist, zumindest wurde diese Debatte nochmal aufgemacht und die wurde
jetzt aber so ein bisschen abmoderiert. Also noch haben wir das nicht abgewendet.
Noch ist dieser Persistent Unique Identifier tatsächlich vorgesehen.
Da stand sogar im Koalitionsvertrag, dass sie das nicht wollen, dass sich stattdessen ein vertrauenswürdiges allgemein anwendbares Identitätsmanagement
sowie die verfassungsfeste Registermodernisierung Priorität hätten.
Und dieses moderne, allgemein anwendbare Identitätsmanagement ist genau die Möglichkeit.
Du kannst dir selber beliebige Identitäten allen möglichen Behörden im Einzelnen gegenüber ausstellen.
Wenn die signiert werden vom Staat, bist du halt an der Stelle derjenige,
kannst die zusammenführen, wenn du möchtest. Das funktioniert in anderen Ländern auch super.
Ist ein gelöstes Problem. Ja, es ist quasi ein gelöstes Problem.
In Deutschland ist, wir wollen einfach ein Primary Key, der irgendwie deine Steuer-ID oder deine,
was auch immer das Merkmal vorher gewesen ist, Nachname plus Geburtsdatum plus Geburtsort oder
oder so. Also wir brauchen irgendwie einen primären Identifier, damit wir, ich weiß nicht mal warum
Ich überlege gerade, von wegen der anekdotischen Evidenz, ich habe neulich die Prämie für das Elektroauto beantragt und da wurde mir gesagt, dazu brauchst du eine Bund-ID und die Bund-ID kannst du total einfach haben, wenn du dein LZ-Zertifikat hier hochlädst.
Also das wird schon sehr gut betrieben, dass man da, also ich glaube es geht auch anders, aber es ist halt so schön einfach.
Wird ja wieder zurückkommen, als Beispiele, was geht, dass z.B. für die Kommunikation
innerhalb der Bundesverwaltung muss man jetzt nicht auf irgendwelche Messenger zurückgreifen,
bei denen man nicht ganz sicher ist, sondern der Bund hat den Bundesmessenger auf Wire
basierend rausgebracht, wo nach einigen Angaben zwischen 22.000 Mitarbeiter in den Behörden
miteinander kommunizieren und wollen jetzt auch Personen außerhalb der Behörden erlauben,
diesen Messenger runterzuladen.
Das war früher ja für Unterpersonen verbreitet, als individueller. Aber jetzt, die haben sich so auf Verwaltung nicht nur in Deutschland spezifiziert kann man sagen.
Na, den Wire an sich gibt's glaube ich gar nicht mehr.
Für Privatleute? Für die Privatleute. Ich weiß nicht, ob's eingestellt ist, das wird auf jeden Fall nicht mehr offensiv, ich glaube es gibt's, also anyways.
Es ist eine Firmenlösung. Es widmet sich nicht mehr an End-User-Innen, sondern quasi an Organisationen.
Und ist es Open Source, weiß das jemand? Jaja, es ist ihnen ganz wichtig, dass es ums Haus ist und in Zukunft auch wieder für die
Bürgerinnen zur Verfügung gestellt wird, für die Behördenkommunikation, dann inzertifiziert,
weil bisher haben sie gesagt, per WhatsApp schreiben ist vielleicht keine gute Idee und
ich denke, dass es war.
Und betrieben wird der ganze Kram genau dieser, dieser, der Bundes-Cloud.
Das heißt, das musste ja, wir kommen jetzt wieder zu dem ITZ-Zug.
Was heißt das ausgedingst?
Das ist, hab ich mir… Internationale… Informationstechnikzentrum.
Informationstechnikzentrum, wow. Ja. Okay. Na das ist schon, also komm, dig da.
Also, man kann sich schlimmere Abkürzungen ausdenken, oder? Ja.
Also, sie haben ja, das sind wie 4200 Leute, die da arbeiten.
Das ist so eine Art IT-Dienstleister. Das ist quasi, genau, die, die dann, was ja eine der Forderungen waren, die wir damals
auch den Koalitionären mit ins Stammbuch geschrieben haben, dass einmal Projektmanagementkompetenzen,
woran es ja am größten gehapert hat, dass der Staat nicht besonders gut war, IT-Projekte
und IT-Großprojekte schon gar nicht zu begleiten, weil ihnen dort einfach die Kompetenz fehlte.
Und dem sind sie mit dem ITZ auf der einen Seite schon mal auch ganz massiv entgegengetreten.
Haben dort mit jetzt für so typische Informatikstudenten ganz lukrative Angebote, was da irgendwie...
Sie sind sehr stolz, dass sie fast 600 Millionen Euro an Leistungsprämien an ihre 4.200 Mitarbeiterinnen
ausgezahlt haben übers letzte Jahr.
Sie gehen dahin und sagen, wir sind total geile Arbeitgeber, wir wollen Digitalisierung
und drücken da irgendwie echt grad voran. Aber dann siehst du, das Ergebnis ist, dass die jetzt in den 25 Rechenzentren, die sie
in Deutschland haben, kannst du ja mal schätzen, wie viele Rechner sie da stehen haben?
25 Rechenzentren, ich hab keine Ahnung, wie viel ist so schnittig in einem Rechenzentrum, wie viele Rechenzentren hat ein Rechenzentrum?
Das sind jetzt nicht riesige Rechenzentren.
Was, wie viel, 25, also 25.000? Ne, die haben so 55.132 Server stehen und wie viele Endgeräte bespielen sie damit?
Du meinst Leute, die da dran sitzen?
Ja. Na, pro Server ein User. Fast.
Zwei schaffen sie. Also sie haben 124.000 Endgeräte und dazu nochmal 27.000 ultramobile Endgeräte.
Na, was ist das? Smartphones?
Und Tablets, genau. Ultramobiles Endgerät, geil! Ja gut, aber die Frage ist, das ITZ ist natürlich älter als die Ampel, das habt ihr jetzt wahrscheinlich
alle vermutet. Aber stopp, du musst mal so sagen, Zwischenschritt.
Bei ganz vielen Dingen, die ihr sagt, sagt ihr jetzt so, naja, aber es kommt ja eigentlich von vorher.
Jetzt muss man, glaube ich, auch mal fairerweise die Frage stellen.
Hätte es denn die Gelegenheit gegeben, Dinge maßgeblich, also, oder andersrum, hätte es hier eine theoretische Situation geben können, die positiv ist, aus Perspektive des Clubs, wo man nicht sagt, das ist aber schon eine ganze Weile in der Mache.
Ich glaube, genau dort ist eins der Beispiele, wo man sieht, dass die Koalition nur das verstanden hat, dass es wichtig ist, Geld hingeworfen hat. Das ist eins von den Dingen, die...
Also, bestehendes Konzept, aber Sie haben es dann sozusagen weiter...
Knirschend, ich will ja jetzt nicht die Regierung hier lobhudeln, aber manchmal muss man einfach
sagen, Kritik da, wo Kritik angemessen ist und dort sehe ich, dass das Geld und die Aufmerksamkeit
an der richtigen Stelle landet.
Es ist halt genauso, wie man sich sowas wünschen würde für langweilige, kritische Infrastruktur.
Also ich benutze dieses Wort kritische Infrastruktur, unpassend, aber für Infrastruktur, die der
Staat erstmal braucht, um zu funktionieren, das soll eigentlich nicht shiny sein, das
Es soll einfach funktionieren und dort sollen genau die Leute hin, die Lust daran haben, Infrastruktur zu basteln.
Da sollen genau die Leute hin, die jetzt nach ihrem Studium für Systemintegration irgendwo gerne auch für Behörden und dann am Ende wieder den Bürger,
der da mit der Regierung interagieren muss oder besser gesagt mit der Verwaltung, da sollen funktionierende IT-Systeme stehen, die einfach nur funktionieren.
Also das klingt für mich so ein bisschen, so an einer grundlegenden Basisinfrastruktur wird gearbeitet und der Rest lässt noch zu wünschen übrig?
Sie haben da auch ein paar Werte umgesetzt. Also die machen sich ein bisschen Gedanken um Nachhaltigkeit, Berechenzentrum, die machen sich Gedanken um freies Software. Also da sind ein paar Sachen, die wir lange fordern, dabei. Da kann man sich drüber freuen.
Ja, da ist zwei Jahre, ist ein sehr kurzer Zeitraum. Wir sehen, dass dort bewusst Entscheidungen in die richtige Richtung weichen gestellt werden, wo es nach zwei Jahren, du schon siehst, dass es in die richtige Richtung geht, aber natürlich noch nicht so weit ist, dass wir jetzt auf der Straße feiern würden.
Genau, es klingt für mich sozusagen so, also die technische Basisinfrastruktur, also die Hardware, das ist ein bisschen falsch sozusagen, aber da doch die Infrastruktur sozusagen, da wird der richtige Weg gegangen, aber bei sozusagen allem, wo es dann so ein bisschen inhaltlich, wo gesellschaftliche Konzepte eine Rolle spielen, wie zum Beispiel eine übergreifende ID in der Kontakteverwaltung sozusagen, da ist noch so ein bisschen.
Man muss die Ehrlichkeit halber sagen, klar, eine Bundesregierung kann nicht alle Stellschrauben stellen. Wir haben ja hier nur auch viele Landesgesetze, wir haben sehr, sehr starke Kommunen, die ja auch eigene rechtliche Möglichkeiten haben und so weiter.
Also man sollte auch nicht überbetonen in einem föderalen Staat, was eine Bundesregierung kann. Deswegen würde ich jetzt, also da werde ich nicht so furchtbar streng.
Das klingt jetzt für mich, als gäbe es im Zeugnis bei Open Source und Digitalisierung der Verwaltung vielleicht sogar eine Zwei?
Oder was sagt ihr? Joa, also ich bin da auch nicht so unzufrieden.
Wir haben eines aber komplett ausgeklammert und das ist ein anderer Arm des Staatlichen Hauses.
Nicht Open Data, sondern tatsächlich den ganzen Gerichtsbereich. Und da gab es tatsächlich zwei ganz spannende Sachen, die auch im Koalitionsvertrag standen. Das eine war eine Novellierung der Zivilprozessordnung, dass Videoverfahren jetzt quasi nochmal leichter erleichtert werden.
Also wo man nicht im Gerichtsteil ist, sondern wo man auch Video callen darf.
Das betrifft aber nur bestimmte Prozesse, da sind wir noch in der Mitte, da wissen wir aber noch nicht, was rauskommt.
Ich dachte, das wäre beschlossen. Oh, ich dachte, das wäre der Entwurf.
Das ist nicht mein Expertenbereich, aber genau. Und das andere ist der Digitalcheck für Gesetze. Also quasi zu gucken, ob Gesetze, die ja natürlich von Menschen mit Jura-Kompetenz verfasst werden, auch aus Perspektive von Digitalkompetenz überhaupt tragfähig sind.
Oder dass eine Art von Standardcheck durchgeführt wird, auch nicht verkehrt.
Ich hab noch was vergessen, was ich beeindruckend fand, was irgendwie auch fast hätte durchrutschen können.
Die Koalition ist angetreten mit der Ansage, wir wollen ein digitales Gesetzgebungsportal schaffen,
über das einsehbar ist, in welcher Phase sich welche Vorhaben befinden.
Gebittwebseite. Habe ich geklickt, war beeindruckend.
Ist der Log4J-Bug da geklickt? Okay, anyways, also ich schreibe eine 2 auf, das ist ja schon mal nicht schlecht.
Naja, man ist halt hinten losgerannt, come on. Wir waren halt nicht gerade vorne.
Willst du jetzt bei der zwei bleiben oder nicht?
Ja, ich kann nicht mit leben.
Ja gut, aber wenn die Leute mit Lernschwierigkeiten auch mal was hinkriegen, ist doch gut.
Vor allen Dingen, weil ja gute Lehre anscheinend da war, ich erinnere mich an das Abschreiben vom…
So, ich hab jetzt hier, ich muss mich wirklich entschuldigen, das ist wirklich sozusagen
mega über den Kamm geschert, aber auch der Zeit geschuldet.
Ich hab jetzt noch so einen Blog, den nenne ich Moderne Zeiten und der hat damit zu tun, Ich vermerke...
16 Jahre ältere Personen, ich darf nichts gegen ältere Personen sagen, da würde ich mich selber meinen, sozusagen, jetzt neue Regierung, also neue Parteien, zum Teil an der Macht, neue Koalition, neue Menschen.
Es gibt ja so ein paar Themen, über die wird jetzt schon mehr diskutiert als in den 16 Jahren Merkel.
Das könnte man glaube ich ganz kurz zusammenfassen mit VOGUE-Agenda, also Klima, Klimakrise bekämpfen,
Diversität, Gleichheit in der Gesellschaft, Nachhaltigkeit, diese ganzen Dinge.
Und das ist natürlich, da ändert sich ja auch alles, also auch der Club zum Beispiel sozusagen.
Und das ist ja die Diskussion zum Digitale, ist ja nicht mehr nur die Diskussion,
fließen da irgendwie Safe Nullen und Einsen und kann das jemand abhören,
sondern ist ja eben auch sozusagen diese digitale Infrastruktur, die wir hier gebaut haben,
die wir alle benutzen, die wirtschaftlich und politisch motiviert ist.
Wie verhält die sich zu den Themen?
Das ist dann die Schlagzeilen, wie viel Kilowattstunden verbraucht eine Open-AI-Anfrage?
Und wie diskriminierend sind eigentlich die neuen KI-Algorithmen?
Und so weiter und so fort. Deswegen möchte ich das so breit fassen und fragen, ist davon was in den digitalen Aspekten des Koalitionsvertrags zu sehen?
Also da würde mir jetzt sozusagen, um ein Beispiel herauszugreifen, auffallen, wenn ich sozusagen eine Koalition wäre, die jetzt irgendwie eine Regierung würde,
würde ich festschreiben wollen, dass bei Technologien, vor allen Dingen bei digitalen Technologien, die zum Bürgerkontakt nützt oder den Menschen sozusagen großzügig ausgelöst sind,
dass darauf hingearbeitet werden muss oder das ein Kriterium ist, dass die diskriminierungsfrei funktioniert, weil das einfach so ein ganz großes Ding ist.
Also was meint man damit? Irgendwie ganz banales Beispiel, automatische Wasserhahn-Sensoren, die nicht mit dunklen Hautfarben funktionieren.
Das übersetzt in KI-Biometrie… Puh, das ist jetzt aber ein lebenswältliches Beispiel.
Naja, um zu zeigen, worum es geht. Ja, ja klar.
Also Technologie soll für alle Menschen unabhängig von Hautfarbe, Geschlecht etc. funktionieren.
Naja, wir müssen aber vielleicht, wenn du diese ganze kulturelle Seite ansprichst, müssen wir glaube ich auch nochmal sagen, dass wir nicht ahnen konnten beim Koalitionsvertrag, dass es einen unglaublichen KI-Hype geben würde.
Und mir persönlich ist schon aufgefallen, dass diese Fragen nach Vorurteilen, nach Bias, also diese, was du jetzt so unter modern fasst, wie selbstverständlich mitdebattiert werden. Also sie sind kein Non-Thema mehr.
Das ist tatsächlich neu für mich. Das habe ich sowohl auf der Brüsseler Ebene wie auf der deutschen Ebene früher als nicht so selbstverständlich empfunden.
Ja, ich sehe da trotzdem eine Lücke im Diskurs. Es wird darüber gesprochen, die Systeme, die Algorithmen die diskriminieren jetzt und
da müssen wir was gegen machen.
Ja, fair, aber dass wir ja nach wie vor auch einfach Lösungen haben, die durch ihre Implementierung
und die Art und Weise, wie sie umgesetzt sind, diskriminieren, ist auch ein Problem.
Es gibt eine Studie vom Paritätischen Wohlfahrtsverband, die ganz spannend aufmacht, wie wohl sich Menschen in Deutschland mit Digitalem fühlen.
Also quasi wie confident, wie zuversichtlich die sind, digitale Services beispielsweise von Verwaltungen in Anspruch zu nehmen.
Und da kommt raus, dass Menschen aus dem Niedriglohnsektor da wirklich, die haben vielleicht ein Endgerät, aber die sagen, sie sind nicht in der Lage oder sie fühlen sich nicht imstande, es stresst sie total, ein Online-Formular ausfüllen zu müssen.
Aber ist das Kulturell? Das ist eine soziale Frage. Das ist eine soziale Frage, genau. Das ist eine eminent soziale Frage.
Aber da kommt Digitalisierung und dann haben wir eine Diskriminierungsfrage wieder zusammen und über diese Ebene debattieren wir nicht.
Ah ok, das heißt die soziale Komponente, die man dazunehmen müsste, wenn man über diese Form der…
Was machen eigentlich diese Rotzen, könnte man das mal zuspitzen, ja?
Du meinst die ehemalige Arbeiterpartei?
Na, was denn? Das sind doch die Sozialdemokraten, die früher die soziale Frage gestellt haben.
Und was ist denn mit Leuten, die sich kein 150 Smartphone oder auch kein 80 Euro Smartphone leisten können? Wie ist es mit dem Zwang zur Digitalisierung? Also ich finde, das ist sehr weit aufgemacht.
Aber notwendig, wenn wir drüber reden, das Querschnittsthema Digitalisierung ist halt dann leider auch echt ein Querschnittsthema.
Naja, vor allen Dingen sozusagen, weil, wenn wir über die sozialen Klassen sprechen, ist es ja sozusagen, je schlechter es dir geht, desto weniger Zeit hast du ja und desto eher bist du darauf angewiesen, dass es vielleicht funktioniert, aber und so weiter und so fort.
Also Klima sind trotzdem auch keine Nicht-Themen, würde ich jetzt auch nicht unbedingt sagen, aber ich finde die soziale Komponente dieser progressiven Agenda ist am wenigsten ausgeprägt, aus meiner Sicht, wenn ich mir so alle Debatten, auch jetzt vielleicht noch ein bisschen Europa mit reinnehme, aber bundesrepublikanisch so ansehe, da ist die finde ich noch am unterrepräsentiersten.
Mein Verdacht ist ja, dass das damit zusammenhängt, weil man sich dann irgendwann fragen müsste,
ob Kapitalismus wirklich die beste aller Ideen ist.
Aber gut, an diesem Moment kommt man ja immer mal wieder im Chaos Radio.
Wie ist es denn mit der, also, oder um es anders zu sagen, also...
Es wird mitgedacht, es findet eine Progressivierung statt, aber es gibt auch blinde Flecken.
Naja, die Zivilgesellschaftseinbindung ist natürlich ein Punkt, der immer dabei ist.
Wen bindest du ein, wen fragst du?
Die Leute mit dem Geldkoffer, oder? Das steht auch im Koalitionsvertrag.
Was denn? Dass die Zivilgesellschaft besser eingebunden wird.
Und? Ich bin da super unzufrieden damit.
Also zum einen, das hat so eine Goodwill-Komponente, es ist oft auch zeitlich pro Urteil knapp.
Das hat man jetzt gerade wieder bei dem BND-Gesetz gesehen. Albern wenig.
Also 5, 20 Stunden, 30 Minuten, bei 88 Seiten.
Aber es ist auch so ein bisschen… Stopp.
Also, Gesetzgebungsprozesse. Ja. Zivilgesellschaft wurde eingebunden.
Lass mich kurz erklären.
Gesetzgebungsprozesse, die passieren ja sozusagen, da werden auch immer Expertinnen befragt und
Und das passiert auch schon weit vorher, manchmal findet man ja in Gesetzestexten nicht nur
Dinge vom Chaos Computer Club wieder, sondern auch von möglicherweise reichten Industriezahlen.
Wirtschaftsverbänden? Würde möglich, also vielleicht.
Es gibt aber den einen Punkt, nämlich bevor das Gesetz dann glaube ich in die parlamentarische
Beratung geht, wo man gesagt hat, liebe Zivilgeschäfte, wollt ihr vielleicht auch was dazu sagen?
Dazu wird der Gesetzesentwurf verschickt und dann wird gesagt, so jetzt habt ihr x amount
und verhaltet euch mal dazu und schickt eine Stellungnahme.
D.h. jemand, der fachlich kompetent ist, muss diesen Gesetzestext lesen und muss was zurückschreiben.
Muss das aber auch so schreiben, dass es Leute lesen, die nicht unbedingt so tief drinstecken wie die Leute,
die gerade das Gesetz gelesen haben.
Dafür ist zu sagen, liebe Leute, wir brauchen das morgen relativ knapp.
Das ist ein bisschen ein Feigenblatt.
Man hat dem Genüge getan, die Zivilgesellschaft war ja angefragt.
Was können wir dafür, wenn die nicht...
Da fragst du, wer ist klassischerweise unterrepräsentiert? Wir wissen ja auch, wer sich in dieser Zivilgesellschaft engagiert und wer das nicht kann. Welche gesellschaftlichen Gruppen da überhaupt nicht repräsentiert sind.
Für mich ist es halt auch eine kulturelle Frage, weil diese Grünen als Teil der Ampel genau aus diesen Bewegungen kommen. So sind die geboren, wenn man jetzt mal die Jahrzehnte und die Parteientwicklung sieht.
Und ich hätte einfach gedacht, es ist ein starker Teil von deren DNA, dass die da anders drüber denken.
Wobei das Spannende ja ist, es gab ja solche Konsultationsverfahren, wie du sie gerade beschrieben hast, Markus, zu anderen Eckpunkte Papier, Gesetzesvorhaben, wo die viel stärker erstens angekündigt wurden, das heißt wir konnten uns alle schon mal emotional sammeln und uns irgendwie einlesen und dann gab es da Konsultationsfristen von irgendwie drei Wochen oder so, ich meine, damit können wir ja arbeiten, aber das Spannende ist doch wieder, bei welchen Gesetzen es nicht gemacht wird. Genau.
Das ist halt wieder Überwachung. Geheimdienste sind sowieso, na gut, da könnte ich jetzt schon wieder den Rant ablassen,
aber bei Geheimdiensten ist es ja sowieso anders. Ich hab da ein gewisses Enttäuschungsgefühl.
Vielleicht war aber auch meine Erwartungshaltung einfach zu groß. Ich habe immer so ein bisschen gedacht, dass es jetzt auch eine gewisse kulturelle Änderung gibt.
Kann ich nachvollziehen, wenn eine ehemalige Arbeiterpartei mit einer Macht ist und den Kanzler stellt den.
Anyways, das ist ja der eine Punkt, jetzt muss ich schon langsam anfangen, Tempo zu machen, um den Koalitionsvertrag zu zitieren.
Was ist denn mit der Nachhaltigkeitsdebatte? Wird sowas auch überlegt? Bundeszentren sollen auf Ökostrom betrieben werden?
Und vielleicht guckt man auch mal, ob man Energie, also wenn man schon Code selber beauftragt, dass der irgendwie energieeffizient funktioniert.
Ganz ehrlich, ich hätte mir nicht träumen lassen, dass die Nachhaltigkeitsdebatte so derart polarisiert wird.
Ich hätte mir nicht träumen lassen, dass wir sozusagen eine ganze rechte Bubble haben, die im Wesentlichen diese Klima- und Nachhaltigkeitsdebatte derart stark politisiert.
Ich hätte mir das einfach nicht träumen lassen. Da hat sich innerhalb von einem Jahr oder anderthalb Jahren unglaublich viel zum Schlechten gewandelt.
Es gibt eine ganze Bevölkerungsschicht, die sozusagen Nachhaltigkeit jetzt als Bedrohung empfindet.
Und auch da ist natürlich diese ganze soziale Frage viel zu wenig adressiert.
Es ist völlig defensiv geworden und ich muss den Heizer mal nochmal ansprechen.
Ich glaube, ohne diese ganze Kampagne gegen...
Einige Gesetzesprojekte der Ampel, ich glaube, hätten wir diese von Popularisierung nicht.
Ich habe den Eindruck, die riechen jetzt irgendwie schlecht.
Was du jetzt gerade machst, ist ein Kommentar zur generellen Politik.
Was ich ja frage, ist, macht die Ampel-Regierung in ihre Digitalpolitik,
spielt da Nachhaltigkeit und Energieeffizienz eine Rolle?
Ja, also wir sind mit dem Schlagwort Green IT auch angetreten.
Was sie jetzt umsetzen, die Rechenzentren, die sie selber betreiben, sind alle mit 100%
Ökostrom betrieben, haben sich auf die Fahne geschrieben.
Unter dem Stichwort Green IT könnt ihr alle googlen, was die sich vorgestellt haben, welche
Lösungen sie dort finden können und was sie umgesetzt haben tatsächlich.
Aber das ist immer nur ein Teil dessen. Du kannst natürlich als Staat mit gutem Beispiel vorangehen, aber wenn du trotzdem sowas, was
Was uns ja ganz doll wichtig war, dass es so Mindesthaltbarkeitsdaten für irgendwelche
Dinge, für Geräte im Laden, dass du nichts mehr verkaufen darfst, was nicht reparierbar
ist, wo nicht Sicherheits- und Software-Updates, wie kein Cloud-Zwang, also dass du keine Dinge
verkaufen darfst, ohne selber zu garantieren, dass wenn es eine Cloud-Komponente gibt, du
die weiter betreiben kannst, das steht alles nirgendwo drinne.
Wie die ganzen Dinge, die machen, dass in großen Mengen Elektroschrott anfällt, hat
hat sich nix bewegt und das ist traurig und in anderen Bereichen hat sich aber Dinge bewegt,
wo der Staat mit eigenen Rechenzentren und eigener IT vorangeht, da ist Nachhaltigkeit schon mehr gedacht.
Das klingt jetzt, also dieses ganze Gebiet klingt für mich wirklich nach einer 3.
Das ist ein Minenfeld geworden und das ist so unsachlich geworden in vielen Bereichen,
wenn man das mal wirklich gesellschaftsverändernd umsetzen wollte, würde das sofort zum krassen
Politikum innerhalb der Ampel. Und das ist für mich ein Hemdschuh.
Mich nervte tierisch, dass diese Nachhaltigkeitsfragen kein Konsens mehr sind.
Man sagt ja manchmal auch so, der größte Hebel irgendwie ist das Vergaberecht, also der Staat investiert Milliarden im Jahr in Geräte, vergibt Aufträge für die Entwicklung von Softwarelösungen, für die Wartung und so weiter.
Und da nochmal mit reinzugehen und da Nachhaltigkeitsaspekte auch nach oben zu setzen auf der Agenda ist ein Hebel.
Und ich glaube, da sind sie auch dran, aber ich weiß tatsächlich nicht, wie der Stand aktuell ist.
Also bei Vergabe heißt es ja üblicherweise, das Billigste muss genommen werden, außer wenn triftige Gründe dagegen sprechen.
Und da halt vielleicht auch zu sagen, Nachhaltigkeit ist immer ein triftiger Grund, um sich gegen das Billigste zu entscheiden.
Also das wären relativ einfache Maßnahmen, die weit tragen, ohne dass man dieses Minenfeld betreten muss, weil das rein intern funktioniert.
Da machen wir auch wieder riesengroße Bereiche noch mit auf, weil mit dem Vergabe könnte man auch gleich sagen, dass die Software nicht mehr gekauft wird,
wenn so eine Firma regelmäßig auffällt, dass ihre Software Bugs hat, die nicht gefixt werden oder dass sowieso keine Prozesse implementiert werden.
Da gibt es viele Bereiche, wo der Staat einfach allein durch Einkauf auch richtige Impulse setzen könnte.
Naja könnte so, was es denn eure Not dafür ist?
Ich bin schon drei, was du gesagt hast, erschlösse ich mich auch nicht.
War ja jetzt nur eine Vermutung. Naja, es ist auch kein Nicht-Thema, ich finde schon, dass es auch bei der Vergabe eine größere
Rolle spielt, aber die Vergabe ist natürlich auch nicht nur bundespolitisch, muss man
wieder einschränkend sagen, wir sind nun mal ein föderaler Staat.
Aber ich würde glaube ich dann auch drei Köpige auch mitleben.
So, und das führt uns jetzt sozusagen schon zum Endspurt.
Weil dann sind wir bei der Durchschnittsnote von 3,4, also 3 minus könnte man sagen.
Das wiederum finde ich jetzt fast schon ein bisschen überraschend gut.
Weil eine 3 ist ja kein Totalausfall. Das ist halt so, ja gut, für die wenige Energie, die ihr da investiert habt, ist das ein ganz
passables Ergebnis eigentlich.
Wie zufrieden seid ihr denn so insgesamt jetzt? Weil, also ich muss schon zugeben, ich hatte an einer Stelle sozusagen das Gefühl, okay,
bei dem Verwaltungs- und Open-Source-Kram, da kann man schon Bemühungen erkennen, aber der Rest war eher so, naja.
Nee, die Frage ist immer, ob die Bemühungen in die richtige Richtung gehen und da war ja bei uns der Daumen eher hoch.
Also, weil Bemühungen tun sie sich ja immer. Lass mir die Frage anders stellen. Es ist ja jetzt Halbjahreszeitung, auf dem Halbjahreszeitung steht eine 3 minus und es gibt ja noch zwei Jahre.
Wird versetzt, willst du fragen? Ne, ne, ne, so läuft das aber nicht in der Legislatur.
Lass mal den Markus fragen.
Was ich fragen möchte ist, für die nächsten zwei Jahre weiter so oder ihr müsst grundlegend an folgenden Dingen arbeiten?
Ja, natürlich. Ich meine, wir reden seit Beginn der Koalition über das Digitalbudget, das wir bis heute nicht verabschiedet haben.
Und wenn das jetzt noch kommt, dann sind da natürlich irgendwie Pfründe drin. Ich finde das prinzipiell nicht verkehrt, aber dann haben wir tatsächlich...
Dann haben wir tatsächlich. Wofür soll das sein?
Das soll tatsächlich diesen ganzen Digitalbereich eigentlich komplett finanzieren.
Insbesondere 18 Leuchtturmprojekte.
Aber die gibt's ja.
Ja, ja. Die leuchten. Das können wir jetzt aber nicht nah aufmachen, oder?
Aber ja, also das müssen sie definitiv machen.
Wir haben noch irgendwie eine Vogelperspektive, die wichtig ist. Stopp.
Forderung eins. Extra Posten für Digitalprojekte im Bundeshaushalt.
Das Digitalbudget, das verhandelt wird, jetzt endlich auch verabschieden und nicht wieder vertagen.
Warum, was tippst du jetzt nieder? Willst du das nachher hinschicken oder was?
Entfielst du das jemandem? Ich treffe morgen den Olaf und dann sag ich mal, lieber Herr Scholz, Sie haben sich ja
bis jetzt noch nicht so richtig auf der Tanzfläche gezeigt, hier sind Ihre Karten, bitte umsetzen.
Wir müssen noch ganz kurz ansprechen, dass wir jetzt nicht realistisch noch zwei Jahre
Zeit haben, sondern nur noch eins.
Ja, dankeschön. Denn du weißt schon, irgendwann geht es wieder in den Wahlkampf über.
Die haben ja immer, also legislativ, wenn du da tätig werden willst, ein kleineres Fenster
als die gesamte Legislaturperiode.
Also dann hauen und stechen. Ich will mich, also sozusagen, im Versuch mich so ein bisschen aus der Fähre zu ziehen,
das ist ja beim Endjahreszeugnis immer so, die Sommerferien, das Zeugnis wird ja nicht
zum Anfang der Sommerferien gegeben, sondern früher.
Nein, aber du musst Gesetzesentwürfe eigentlich jetzt, also jetzt und ein paar Wochen, dann ist es vorbei.
Und es ist ja schlimmer als Sommerferien, sondern dann geht ja diese komische Klientelpolitik
wieder los mit den Ressourcen, die noch da sind.
Dann wird es ja immer so ein bisschen irrational alles und das wollen wir eigentlich eben verhindern.
Den Europawahlkampf und jetzt noch Hessen und Bayern, also die Wahlkämpfe sind ja auch nicht nur im Bund und insofern,
Prinzip ist das jetzt schon mit Entzeugnis.
Wenn du den Olaf morgen triffst, geh mal da her und sag, Olaf, deine Vorgängerin hat was von Neuland gefaselt,
du könntest jetzt mal hergehen, ich als digital native.
Würde mir jetzt wünschen, dass die Gesellschaft sich das auf die Fahnen schreibt, selber weiterzubilden im Digitalen, die Möglichkeiten wahrzunehmen, sich weiterzuentwickeln,
zu entwickeln, souverän mit dem umzugehen, dafür ist doch genau so ein Bundeskanzler
da.
Warum sollte denn aber Markus' Phrasen dröscher werden? Was du machst, genau, wollte gerade sagen, das klingt sozusagen nach einem Heißluftballon,
was meinst du?
Was soll die Ampelregierung machen? Nein, nein, nein, du wolltest mit Olaf dich treffen und ich dachte, dass du könntest
ihm sagen... Ich rede mit dem Tacheles, keine Politiker-Phrasen.
Was soll er machen? Achso, sind die Türen zu? Ist das seine Aufgabe auch?
Ich habe jetzt die Merkel, die sich hingestellt hat und meinte, das ist für uns alle Neuland
und damit eine Entschuldigung für viele geliefert hat, sich mit diesem ganzen Digitalgedöns
nicht auseinanderzusetzen.
Demgegenüber würde ich gerne an der Spitze des Staates, na gut, zumindest an der Spitze
der Regierung, irgendjemanden entgegenstellen, der mal sagt, nee, das ist alles nicht so,
wir müssen das als sowie Hochtechnologieland, müssen wir wie selbstverständlich damit umgehen.
Der Fisch stinkt doch dann immer vom Kopf her, wenn dort Leute stehen, die irgendwie
rumwabern und mit dem Digitalen nichts zu tun haben wollen, dann siehst du das auch in der Gesellschaft.
Das heißt, sag dem Olaf, der soll mal irgendwie auch ganz selbstverständlich von, keine Ahnung,
seinem selbst gewastelten PC berichten oder so.
Was?
Ich möchte eine positive Vision formulieren, wie irgendwie so eine Regierung neben der
Gesetzgebungskompetenzen, die sie haben, auch durch Vorbildwirkung gesetzt…
Gut, dass du nichts mit Worten machst. Ich schreib mal auf, Selbstverständlichkeit der digitalen Perspektive.
Oh Gott. Okay, ja, also, Konz?
Was? Deine Forderung für die Zeit nach dem Halbjahreszeugnis formuliere ich jetzt mal ganz vorsichtig.
Ich glaube, dass ein Schlüssel, um noch ein paar Sachen hinzukriegen ist, also hat mit
der Zivilgesellschaft zu tun.
Das eine ist Wissen und Sachkenntnis über viele Bereiche und auch Analysen gibt es ja eine Menge.
Und die Frage ist immer, wen man für was heranzieht. Also was jetzt noch kommt an Gesetzentwürfen und tatsächlich Entscheidungen, die noch
durchgezogen werden kann, da würde ich mir insbesondere wünschen, dass eine größere
Breite der Zivilgesellschaft beteiligt wird.
Ich halte das für essenziell und auch für, naja, in dem Sinne einer progressiven und
irgendwie kulturell modernen Agenda für wichtig.
Und das Zweite ist, ich würde mir – Aber auch tatsächlich beteiligt, oder?
Lass mich den Gedanken nochmal kurz – was ich mir so wünschte, ist, sich in gewisser
dieser ganzen Wissenschaftsfeindlichkeit, die krassiert so entgegenzustellen und diese Sachliche mehr in den Vordergrund zu stellen und auch mal gegen Wirtschaftsinteressen.
Also ich meine, da fände ich, also den Mut zu haben, fände ich wichtig, aber ich sehe den, wenn ich ehrlich bin, natürlich jetzt wenig.
Also ein paar Entscheidungen, die jetzt anstehen, auch im Digitalen, wären halt eher so teuer und nicht so unbedingt so populär sein, weißt du so. Zum Beispiel?
Naja, insbesondere bei den Überwachungsfragen, die wir am Anfang hatten, das wird nicht unbedingt populär sein.
Was wird nicht populär sein? Überleg dir doch mal. Vor allem, was wird daran teuer?
Was wird daran teuer, nichts zu überwachen?
Achso, das meinte ich jetzt bei der Digitalisierung. Achso.
Klar, wenn man da unabhängig und nachhaltig agieren will, ist das nicht unbedingt die billigste Variante.
Ich weiß nicht, ich hätte halt manchmal die Hoffnung, dass sie so ein bisschen mehr gegen den Stachel locken und so ein bisschen auch den Mut hätten, ihre Ideen da vorzutragen. Aber innerhalb der Ampel sind sie sich ja leider auch nicht einig.
Na gut. Jetzt bin ich aber wieder sehr, oh boah, jetzt hab ich echt weit ausgeholt. Tut mir leid.
Ja, ich bin interessanterweise jetzt am Ende der Sendung nicht...
Nicht ganz hoffnungslos, aber schon so ein bisschen zynisiert. Zynisch?
Naja, nee, ich finde das schöne englische Wort jaded, das beschreibt es noch besser,
also zynisch und gleichzeitig abgestumpft, also quasi froh, dass es immerhin eine 3,4
geworden ist und vielleicht wird es ja nicht sehr viel schlimmer.
Also eine Genasialempfehlung gibt es damit nicht, versetzt und gefährdet ist aber auch nicht.
Und guckt euch mal bitte die Wahlumfragen an, da werden wir noch fröhlich auf die Ampel zurückblicken, hallo? Wenn uns erstmal irgendwie CDU und AfD regiert. Guten Tag!
Ich bin mir übrigens nicht ganz sicher, ob man dieses Meme verbreiten sollte, weil ja, es gibt sozusagen Schaubilder, die das zeigen, aber das sind ja alles sozusagen statistische Dinge.
Von zweifelhafter Herkunft und ich habe mich neulich sozusagen darüber aufgeregt, dass.
Ein ehemals progressives Platt damit getitelt hat, ob es denn denkbar wäre, wenn jetzt
so ein AfD-Typ Ministerpräsident ist.
Und damit verschiebt man natürlich, deswegen weiß ich nicht, ob man das auch herbeireden kann.
Ich möchte es gar nicht herbeireden, keine Sorge, ich könnte es nicht herbeireden.
Aber ich habe gerade nochmal einen Kommentar aufgemacht, den Markus Becke da auf messpolitik.org
geschrieben hatte, als der Koalitionsvertrag ganz frisch rausgekommen war, also der erste Kommentar dazu.
Der Titel ist Ampel verspricht Stärkung digitaler Grundrechte und da wird's doch spannend,
weil wenn wir, ob der jetzt herbeigeredet ist oder wann eher passiert, ist wahrscheinlich
eher die Frage, in dieser ganzen zivilgesellschaftlichen Bedrohungslage, in der sich inzwischen echt
viele in dieser Gesellschaft befinden, weil sie angegangen werden, weil sie gedoxt werden
und so weiter, haben wir da jetzt eine Stärkung unserer digitalen Grundrechte?
I don't see it.
Und ganz ehrlich, das bräuchten wir doch nicht. Dafür steht nur Buschmann, aber er hat halt keinen sehr starken Stand, finde ich.
Na, das ist ja schön. Jetzt hast du aber auch herausgefordert, dass wir negativer werden.
Ich habe nur nach dem gefragt, was es ist.
Anyways, also liebe HörerInnen, es war sehr schön, dass ihr dabei wart.
Wir nehmen Kommentare, ne? Also ihr könnt ja selber sagen, was ihr sagen würdet.
Ihr könnt gerne ein anderes Talk das ausstellen oder dasselbe unterstreichen.
Könnt sozusagen wie die Eltern unterschreiben, was wir hier gerade verurteilt haben. Oder nicht?
Sagen wir like und subscribe? Like und subscribe, abonniert, genau, tragt die Gründe weiter.
Drückt die Glocke.
Drückt die, haben wir eine Glocke? Wir müssen eine Glocke auf den Block einbauen, damit man auch die Glocke drücken kann.
Erdgeist, Elisa und Konz, vielen Dank, dass ihr dabei wart und das so schön auseinander dividiert habt.
Und ihr liebe Hörerinnen, es bleibt mir vor allen Dingen heute wieder mal zu sagen, lasst
euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.
Tschüss.
Music.